This guy is out of his mind. What a What a Oh, Ethan Klein only
sues or fights with people he thinks are weaker than him. He
is a cowardly spineless What is wrong with this guy? What is
wrong with Ethan Klein? He called the post he did for his own
video a Nazi salute. Are you kidding me? He will never fight
with somebody bigger than him, stronger than him in any possible
way. He will always cower in the shadows and pick fights with
people he's bigger than and try to beat them down. You are psychotic.
You are psychotic.
We're going to read the lawsuit.
All right, perfect perfect perfect. So, introduction. Bennett
Noah Samson Samson advocates that the only solution to the genocide
of Palestinians is the genocide of Israelis, even if they vocally
support the Palestinian cause. Is that what he called for? Through
his entity Samson Creative LLC, Samson published a video on YouTube
entitled the YouTubers who back to
The thumbnail for the defamatory video depicts various individuals
including plaintiff Ethan Klein.
Samson knew that Ethan vociferously advocated against the genocide
of Palestinians. Despite this, yeah, this is not This is already
If this is ever his argument If his argument is, "Well, actually
I said genocide's bad."
This is over. This is over immediately.
"Well, actually I said genocide's is bad." That's not the argument
he makes.
The argument is he makes a very specific argument. You'd have
to say what facts what factual statements are incorrect or implied
to be incorrect from that, right? You support a genocide because
you manufacture consent by constantly like obfuscating, by constantly
attacking the people who are actually pointing out the things
that are happening. This is why I think you support a genocide.
That is an opinion and that is a political opinion. Particularly
hard to go after political opinions in the state of California,
okay?
If there's a political opinion in a public interest and you're
expressing that opinion, right? And it's like a an emotionally
driven opinion, you basically can't call that
There is no factual claim being made. You support a genocide.
Right? That's not a factual claim. That is an opinion.
You You manufacture consent for a genocide. That is an opinion.
Anyway, we continue. They published the defamatory video to falsely
paint Ethan as supporting genocide. Defendant's defamatory video
was incredibly successful. To date it has received approximately
1.5 million views and is defendant's second most viewed video
on YouTube. Ethan and his wife Hila Klein, Hila, are passionate
advocates of the rights of Palestinians to self-determination
and establishment of a Palestinian state. They are vehement critics
of the Israeli government and Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu.
Benyamin Benyamin Bibi Netanyahu.
Both before and after October 7th, Ethan and Hila condemned Israel's
oppression and violence towards the Palestinian people including
explicitly stating Israel's actions constituted genocide.
Ethan and Hila advocate for a two-state solution to resolve the
conflict. Both Ethan and Hila are Israelis, Ethan by naturalization
and Hila by birth. Nearly all of Hila's family reside in Israel.
Hila and her family are also Mizrahi
from Arab and Muslim countries who came to Israel as refugees
escaping violence and oppression. Both Ethan and Hila know that
if Jews were to be expelled from Israel, the vast majority would
have nowhere to go. This is the primary reason they advocate
for a two-state solution instead of a one-state
So, this is just another lawsuit by the way where it's like there
are no facts being laid out. Like it's immediately just a PR
lawsuit.
Like this is just a PR lawsuit. Feel bad for me. Don't you Oh,
woe is me. Woe is me. I'm Ethan Klein and everybody hates
Yeah, for good reason. For like this.
Stop being a crybully, how about?
Stop being a crybully. Nobody likes it. Everybody hates it.
Samson makes his position on Israel-Palestine conflict the Israel-Palestine
conflict unequivocally clear. Oh, right. So, Ethan's actually
doing the same thing. Right? Ethan's making the same argument
back in his lawsuit. This immediately invalidates the lawsuit.
He is going to argue that Noah Samson advocates that the only
way to prevent the Palestinians is the genocide of Israelis.
So, you're saying by Noah Samson are advocating for a one-state
solution. Despite him thinking that that could be done peaceably,
that that's him advocating for the genocide of Israelis. You're
making some like future prediction on how his rhetoric will affect
the world.
Likewise, Noah Samson is saying you're manufacturing consent
for a genocide by constantly attacking people who are pointing
out what's happening, by constantly doing all of these things.
You are manufacturing consent for a genocide. I think your actions
will lead to more Palestinians being killed. They are doing the
exact same thing. Ethan has done this in the first line of his
lawsuit. It's over. It's already over, right? That's exactly
where he is going to go. Because he's trying to make the one-state
versus two-state solution argument in a legal document for some
reason. Random aside, I remember Erudite and others said Denims
was being anti-Semitic for taking pictures of her OF with the
pages of Ethan's hit lawsuit with Hitler. It's dude, yeah. Why
did Ethan put pictures of Hitler in that lawsuit? Very
So, I think you've already sort of like lost the plot entirely
when you're doing the same sort of argument, the exact same kind
of argument to establish something to establish that he wants
Right? You're basically doing the exact same like downstream
argument that that Noah is doing to you.
Samson makes his position on Israel-Palestine conflict unequivocally
clear. Israel must be wiped off the face of the earth. He advocates
that anyone that who supports the existence of Israel is a valid
target. He is an adamant believer of there are no bad means only
bad targets. As such, he engages in very similar behavior rhetoric
he purportedly condemns to paint his targets as evil.
In the very behavior, sorry. The very behavior and rhetoric he
purports purportedly condemns to paint his targets as evil. I
see. The same rhetoric. I mean, it's mostly generated from an
empathetic place. Ethan's angst here is generated from like empty
for himself, for feeling attacked. Like he's the victim. He's
He's feeling like the victim himself.
Noah doesn't feel like the victim himself. Noah feels empathy
for the Palestinians, right? It's a different
I And I feel like it's more justified. You're You're more
To me it feels more justified. Now, that doesn't give you the
right to lie about people and Noah has lied about people. I know
he has.
I just don't see where it happened with
Samson knows that Ethan has condemned Israel's actions as genocide.
He simply does not care about this fact. Samson brands Ethan
a genocide supporter because he does not advocate for the complete
destruction of Israel and
That's not what [clears throat] he argued. That's not what he
argued at
Defendant's defamatory video seeks to prove as a factual matter
that Ethan advocates for the genocide of Palestinians. It achieves
its objectives by its objective by one, misrepresenting source
materials, two, relying on clearly biased sources and some of
which have spread falsehoods about Ethan, and three, through
other defamatory statements about Ethan. The law This lawsuit
seeks to prove that advocacy for the Palestinian cause does not
require falsely branding advocates of a two-state solution as
sanctioning genocide. Why don't I don't think he's like Maybe
I missed it. Did he say
Thinking your own victimization isn't empathetic. It's
Uh sorry, thinking about your own victimization isn't empathetic.
Yeah, it's not, obviously. So,
it's very interesting.
I wonder does Noah say that? Like all advocates of a two-state
solution are sanctioning
This lawsuit seeks to prove an arguably very contentious political
point. LOL. Yeah, exactly LitigiousGamer.
And it's like like it's literally explicitly protected speech.
Like you are not going to ever ever restrict somebody's political
speech. It's like basically the point of the First Amendment.
And it is explicitly political speech that's happening here.
Yeah, it's it's crazy. The lawsuit seeks to prove that advocacy
for the Palestinian cause does not require falsely branding advocates
of a two-state solution as sanctioning genocide. To the contrary,
doing so impedes the Palestinian cause because it engages in
the very behavior these so-called advocates purport to condemn.
This is exactly what Samson did and why defendants must be held
accountable for falsely asserting that Ethan advocates the genocide
of Palestinians despite knowing that this statement is false.
I just need you guys to know that we are totally against the
genocide. I've said Bibi Netanyahu's a war criminal. I've said
Israel's actions suck right now. I've said I don't like what's
going on in Gaza. How could you possibly say I am supporting
a genocide in any way? That's going to be what it is.
Okay? That's going to be what it is. So, Ethan along with his
wife Hila are amongst the most recognized YouTube content creators.
Through their entity Ten Entertainment Inc. TEI, they own various
YouTube channels including H3H3 Productions with over 5.5 million
subscribers, the H3 Podcast with over 2.5 million subscribers,
Hila Klein
Hila Klein fka Ethan and Hila. Oh, with over 1.7 Oh, sorry. Hila
Klein the channel Hila Klein with over 1.7 million subs and the
H3 Podcast Highlights with nearly 1.5 million subs. They also
own the streetwear company Teddy Fresh. Ethan and Hila first
met in Israel nearly 20 years ago. After meeting, Ethan decided
to move to Israel to be with Hila. As a result, Ethan became
a naturalized citizen of Israel. Hila was born in Israel and
a large portion of her immediate and extended family live in
Israel. A few years after getting married, Ethan and Hila moved
to the United States.
They have been outspoke outspoken supporters of the cause for
Palestinian self-determination and statehood. They are also vociferous
critics of the state of Israel even before October 7th. Noteworthy
examples include On November 11th, 2017, I'm I don't think anybody
is doing this based on his statements from before the war, right?
I don't think anybody is saying based on statements from before,
so these are all going to be irrelevant.
But in any case, we'll read them. On November 11th, 2017, Ethan
conducted an interview with Ela. During the interview, they engaged
in a nuanced conversation about the Israel-Palestine conflict
and expressed strong criticism of the Israeli government and
the
The IDF is what I was going to say. The
I I Dude, my brain just broke trying to figure out whether to
say Israel Defense Forces or IDF. The IDF.
Ela also discussed how much she detested serving in the IDF,
where she served as a secretary.
Is that all she said about it? On December 8th, 2020, Ethan conducted
a conversation with his co-host at the time, Trisha Paytas, about
the Israel-Palestine conflict. He explained to Paytas why she
should not be dismissive of the Free Palestine movement and understand
the Palestinian perspective of the conflict, even referring to
Israel's actions against the Palestinian people as a genocide
and
On May 15th, 2021, Ethan made an Instagram post condemning Israel
and Benjamin Netanyahu, which was liked by Yua because she agreed
with it. This occurred during the Unity Intifada that took place
from May 10th, 2021 through May 21st, 2021. The post was made
specifically in response to the IDF destroying the Al-Jalaa building,
which hosts Al Jazeera and the Associated Press. On October 9th,
2023, 2 days after October 7th, Ethan, Ela, and the crew of the
H3 Podcast discussed how innocent Palestinians would suffer from
Israel's reaction to October 7th because the Israeli government
is barbaric, genocidal freaks, and genocidal war criminals, amongst
other criticisms.
On October 12th, 2023, Ethan conducted a near 4-hour conversation
about the conflict where he described Israel's actions against
the Palestinians as a genocide, openly wept recalling the image
of a Palestinian father holding his dead infant child, and called
Benjamin Netanyahu a war criminal, amongst many other statements.
Yeah, none of this really has to do with any of the arguments
Noah made. So, this is all totally irrelevant. It's all like
entirely irrelevant.
Like what if
what if somebody had been like a big fan of before they joined
the Nazi Party?
Like, would that be relevant? Could you bring this up at
like Nuremberg? Well, actually, before the Holocaust, before
he joined the Nazi Party, before he joined the army, he was a
big fan of Jewish people.
No, that doesn't make any sense.
That makes no sense.
Not that I think Ethan Klein's like particularly bloodthirsty.
It's just, you know, it is what it is. So, amongst many other
statements showing support and empathy for the Palestinian people,
on November 20th, 2023, Ethan and the crew of the H3 Podcast
discussed their hope of seeing a ceasefire and an end to the
atrocities in Gaza. On March 2nd, 2024, Ethan reiterated that
he considers Israel's treatments of treatment of the Palestinians
to be an apartheid and a genocide.
Okay. Okay. I I've just I'm looking for where he's making recommendations
about how to stop this from happening. Where is he Where is he
condemning the things Israel's doing and saying this needs to
stop immediately. I'm going to fundraise to stop this. Anything
like that. I'm looking I'm looking for stuff like that that's
like proving your your you feel like actual empathy here instead
of just sort of virtue signaling.
Um Not that you have to go either way. Just I'm saying that when
he's making the manufacturing consent argument, you're not really
fighting against the manufacturing consent argument. You're basically
just saying, well, I virtue signal. What the I I virtue signal,
what the hell?
On November 25th, 2024, Ethan had an hour and a half conversation
with the Arab online creator, Lowerbox,
about the history of Israeli the Israeli-Arab conflict. Wait.
Hold on. I Correct me if I'm wrong. Is Lowerbox like a Lebanese
I thought he was Lebanese Like I I thought the Lebanese Christian
people were more of like Mediterranean types. According to Drew
Pavlou, Lowerbox is
Like I just said, Eastern Mediterranean. These people are all
They've been together a long time, okay? They're not very different.
On May 23rd, 2025, Ethan had an hour-long conversation with the
Palestinian activist and scholar, Ahmed Fouad Al
Al Khatib, about pragmatic solutions to the conflict. Ethan and
Ela have also made numerous donations to Palestinian-focused
charities. On October 16th, 2023, Ethan and Ela donated $6,500
to a fundraiser for the charitable organizations called Anera,
Palestinian Children's Relief Fund, Palestinian Red Crescent
Society, and Medical Aid for Palestinians.
On May 17th, 2025, Ethan and Ela donated $1,250 to a fundraiser
for the charitable organization called Palestinian or Palestine
Children Relief
So, $1,000 to the World Food Programme's Gaza Fund and $1,000
to Re-Line for
On September 28th, 2025, Ethan and Ela donated $1,000 to a fundraiser
for the Palestine Palestine Children Relief Fund. Critically,
on January 31st, 2025, Ethan and Ela, through their production
company, TEI, released a feature-length documentary called Content
Nuke: Hasan [__] Critically.
Way more important than any of the donations we've made, way
more important than anything else we've done to advocate for
the Palestinians,
we produced, critically,
the Content Nuke on Hasan [__] Are you serious right
now?
What? Dude, what?
Why would you say critically?
Why would you say like critically as in more important than anything
else we've We produced the Content Nuke on Hasan Pi
The Nuke documented how the prominent political streamer, Hasan
[__] repeatedly terrorist organizations, namely Ansar
Allah, aka the Houthis, Hezbollah, and Hamas. During the Nuke,
Ethan repeated and emphasized his condemnation of Israel's treatment
of the Palestinians. I just want to make it clear, guys, that
I totally condemn the Palestinians, but the only people putting
up any sort of fight on their behalf whatsoever
And I I understand there's arguments that they're not putting
up any fight on their behalf, but the only people who are even
remotely showing like, you know, some level of military concern,
some level of like martial concern, are these three groups.
F those groups. Those groups, okay? Those groups in particular
It's very funny. It's just very funny.
I don't know if I'd say that like the Houthis really contributed
to anything positive happening for Israel, or sorry, for the
Palestinians.
Uh obviously, Hamas.
Yikes. Hezbollah. Yeah, nothing really. Honestly, Hezbollah has
just kind of sort of been a positive Hezbollah is like the like
Israel's smart thing in like a silver lobby, and Hezbollah is
like the people they just keep beating up on to look good for
the rest of the world. I don't know that Hezbollah has done a
ton to help either. Hezbollah would help if they invaded Southern
Lebanon, I thought, but then they
Also, that's gone rough, so I don't
Keep thinking of that whole clip with
Israel just keeps winning over Hezbollah, you know? They're They're
never going to repeat that same mistake. They're never going
to go in on the ground. Oh, this lawsuit is insane, Larry McGoogle.
I'm not supporting the lawsuit. I'm just reading the sections
of it.
I think this lawsuit is insane at a base
and it's it's even more of a slap suit
than the one against, you know, Denims. I would say there's like
two things that differentiate it. I think it's more frivolous
than those lawsuits. But, I also think it's a little less inhuman
in that like at least there aren't potential statutory damages
that could be life-ruining for for Noah. Like, at least he's
basically only going to be stuck possibly with legal fees. It
gives him a like reasonable expectation that he can fight this.
If he had potentially like life-ruining statutory damages added
on top of that, I think, personally,
that this would be even worse. But, luckily, that's not there.
You know, I I said if he really hated what Denims said about
him, sue her for defamation. Here he is suing Noah Samson for
defamation. I think it's particularly sick that he's suing Noah
Samson for defamation, apparently
over a video that was mostly documenting his really war crimes.
That seems like that's a bad look. That's a really bad look for
Ethan, but you know, I'm not I'm not in the mind of Ethan Klein,
okay? If Ethan wins, he's getting sued by everyone he's made
videos about. Ethan's not winning this. This is very You'd be
very, very lucky if this even makes it to trial, if this isn't
dismissed almost immediately. Like, I I think you'd you'd probably
be lucky in that case because it seems like you'd have to give
Well, we'll We're about to go through it, okay? We're about to
have timestamps and everything to see all of the references and
see exactly what Noah Samson was talking about. All right? Very
lucky.
If I ever started getting big, I'd make a deal with myself not
to start legal you know, Yeah, well, that's how all creators
feel. It's basically like unless something is explicitly defa-
defamatory, like if you're saying somebody someone and that didn't
happen, right? And they know it didn't happen and you've like
given them a cease and desist. This is This is supporting a genocide.
It's making a political argument. It's very different, right?
This is like saying, you know, Republicans cut USAID.
And it's like saying Republicans, you know, it's like suing Bosch
for saying Republicans covet
Like, okay, that's a political opinion. It's like a charged opinion
in the first place. Nobody takes that as fact. Nobody hears that
thing and thinks it's a fact,
Nobody hears that and says, oh, I think Republicans like openly
go and chant like death to all humanity.
That's not what it is.
Not it.
So, that's that's what this whole video was. Maybe there's links
to other videos, though. Let's see. Samson publishes videos on
YouTube through the his entity, Samson Creative. Throughout his
career, he has produced video essays on various social topics.
In these video essays, he frequently attempts to prove his thesis
by citing various materials.
Prior to October 7th, I don't know why I said that. It was very
Canadian. October
Samson never made a video about the Israel-Palestine conflict.
Rather, he made videos about online drama, along with attacking
conservatives and anti-woke content. After October 7th, Samson
suddenly became a self-styled expert in the Israel-Palestine
conflict. Yeah, didn't he do a whole video on this how he felt
like really uh like incapable of focusing on anything else? I
thought he had a very empathetic
I like I didn't think that video was like gross or anything.
He was like, "Hey, I've I'm seeing war crimes happen and I feel
compelled to speak on this, so I'm going to start doing videos
on
I that seems like very human.
Anyway, throughout his online career, Samson has a notorious
for sloppy research, misrepresenting his sources, and making
false statements.
Okay, that's like character evidence that's totally irrelevant
to this case.
Despite claiming to support women of color and people of color,
including Palestinians, the disingenuousness of Samson's advocacy
comes through when he ruthlessly attacks women and people of
color who do not share his opinions. I love that Ethan Ethan
really hated when people said this about him. He's like using
the lawsuit to do all of the things that he said that Noah did
to him. It's very funny. Not in that like I think it means anything.
You can talk your [__] I think it's funny that he's
like very cowardly about it. It's It's very cowardly. It's very
funny.
Why did you just say two women of color? You mean three women.
So, three women. Three women.
All right. Below are notable examples. Samson is notorious for
his attack on Patience Zina, a black female creator who resides
in the United Kingdom.
She makes videos with nuanced commentary
on various social topics, including race and gender issues. During
the public controversy controversy of Halle Bailey being cast
as Ariel in The Little Mermaid, Patience Zina agreed with the
criticism because she felt Hollywood was shoehorning people of
color into Caucasian stories. Her solution was that Hollywood
should focus on more
focus on creating more content that focuses on stories involving
directly involving, sorry, people of color. Samson attacked Patience
Zina for her opinion and not rubber stamping Halle Bailey's Haley
Haley Bailey's
No, Halle. Halle Bailey's casting. Patience Zina made a video
exposing Samson's hypocrisy.
Why why did you just add this?
Holy relevance. Your honor, relevance? YOUR HONOR, RELEVANCE?
WHAT IS THIS RELEVANT TO? ARE YOU Why did you WHY DID YOU JUST
PUT THIS in a lawsuit? How Why did you pay a lawyer to put this
in a lawsuit? Are you a
Holy
man, whatever. Samson has also attacked Palestinians
Why didn't um
Why didn't Nicholas DeOrio tell Ethan to include the Chud Logic
thing in here? Why didn't Why didn't she Why didn't he do that?
That's like the best example of defamation, though.
There's like two really good examples of defamation that I think
Noah Samson's engaged in. There's the stuff he said about Learnbots
and there's the stuff he said about Chud. I I don't know why
you wouldn't use those. Those are way better examples. These
again are like um these are like opinions again. Samson also
attacked Palestinians who do not give full-throated support to
Hamas and the destruction of Israel. Ahmed Fouad Alkhatib, discussed
above, is a Gazan refugee. He's a senior fellow of the Atlantic
Council, where he leads a non-profit organization called Re-Imagined
for Palestine. He's an advocate of non-violence and the two-state
solution to resolve the conflict between Israel and Palestine.
Samson attacked Alkhatib by calling him a pro-Israel genocide
collaborator that lies for money to help Israel genocide his
people.
We'd have to look We'd have to look into this guy a little bit
more.
So, this is why I don't trust allies. So, full video linked.
Just watch the full video. This guy is a person and then Noah
Samson said something about
Uh-oh. That went back That went Oh, account suspended. Unlucky.
Pack Watch on Noah Samson. I'll We can look up a archive of it
or something after. Let's go up down.
Where are we here? We are on to
the defamatory video. So, all of this was worthless. Just a bunch
of worthless garbage. Thank you, Ethan Klein, for wasting everybody's
time. Appreciate you. On March 11th, 2025, defendants published
a video entitled The YouTubers Who Backed a Genocide, i.e., the
defamatory video. The defamatory video statements contained in
the defamatory video Sorry, the defamatory statements contained
in the defamatory video are identified below.
Defamatory statements. The first defamatory statement is comprised
of the thumbnail and title of the defamatory video, i.e., The
YouTubers Who Backed a Genocide. So, this is easily an opinion
So, it is Ethan, Mutahar, Learnbots, Turkey Tom, and Destiny.
The background of the thumbnail was the devastated landscape
of the Gaza Strip with a photoshopped Israeli flag. The thumbnail
depicted Ethan performing a Nazi salute to the flag. Okay, really?
That's not a Nazi salute.
You don't Nazi salute to your to the side. So, immediately no.
You have to check the content nuke thumbnail. Is it literally
him from the content nuke thumbnail? Hold on. Content nuke
>> Hasan [__]
Content nuke Hasan [__] Oh, whoops. Hold on. H3 Productions.
Is it just him in the thumbnail? Why did he depict himself doing
a Nazi salute?
Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude.
I'm sorry.
J&R and its consequences are a have been a disaster for the
entire content creation space, okay? This guy is out of his mind.
What a What A OH.
AH. [screaming]
WHAT is wrong with this guy?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH ETHAN KLEIN?
HE CALLED the pose he did for his own video a Nazi salute. Are
you kidding me? For his own video. How dare Noah Samson
depict him doing a Nazi salute. That's
absolutely wild. Just in case you were
just how how effective how good this lawsuit's going to be, okay?
Incredibly
Incred- Incredibly embarrassing.
this first one, by the way, these are all opinions. These are
not contextualized at all. These are just opinions that these
people have backed a genocide. He makes an argument for why he
believes they're backing a genocide,
It's pretty obvious that you can't even argue against this that
this is a valid opinion to have. It might be a dumb opinion.
It's a valid opinion. This is the same thing I said before when
it was originally like Sorry, when it was originally threatened.
Silly to do this.
The second statement is Samson's false factual assertion that
Ethan spreads atrocity propaganda. He shares the Hamas mass hoaxes.
The same hoax that was used by Western media, the US government,
and the Israeli government to justify genocide. The second defamatory
statement. Okay, why
did Ethan never say this at all? Hold on. Defamatory video 43:15
to 43:32.
Let's go to the defamatory video in question. Return to Ethan's
video. In the content nuke, you can find just about every type
of what we just looked at in terms of manufacturing consent.
Ethan spreads atrocity propaganda. He shares the Hamas mass hoaxes.
The same hoax that was used by the Western media, the US government,
and the Israeli government to justify a genocide. He cites the
same sources that these parties cite when they go on stage to
legitimize more military killing machinery shipment. Okay, so
the defamatory statement here is not So, it's it's about whether
or not Ethan shares some of these documents and some of these
ideas. Right? I believe
So, if we go to the Ethan Klein Would this be the Ethan Klein
Hasan debate where Ethan presses him on this and says there was
mass rapes? Cuz I do believe that's the differentiation Noah's
going to make. That's the differentiation everybody else is going
to make, right?
Cuz this I would say is factually true that you can you can make
the this exact argument, right? That like these things
obviously How would we put it? They're obviously like played
up. They're obviously like they're The evidence is not there
that mass
coordinated in any ways violence mass occurred. There is disparate
violence. Nobody's denying that. There were people who were raped,
but it was not used as weapon of war. It was not a crime It was
It was not done in a way where they were intentionally trying
to demean or dehumanize the Israelis with
That's like not what was happening. That's not the whole thing.
It's the idea that you think if I find like that you're told
if you find an Israeli woman, you need to you need to do this
to them in order to get our message across.
You know what I mean? It's not that mindset. It's like crimes
of opportunity that are happening, which are obviously evil and
I don't want to take away obviously any is like dehumanizing
inherently. But I'm saying it's not like this mindset of I need
to these people to dehumanize them and and make them lesser.
That's like that it's a crime of passion that's happening in
the moment because you are killing people, right? I I don't like
I'm I'm not going to say unfortunately it's just the thing soldiers
do. Like it's always inexcusable, right?
I don't know if mass implies it was
I do believe this is the idea like the the term mass right? Implies
that there were multiple events and that this was like a a pattern
that you could say repeatedly over and over again showed its
ugly head. Like that that every time they went somewhere and
killed somebody, that was a consistent pattern. I don't think
you can say that. I think you could say there were many cases
of violence. The evidence that comes about and I I haven't gone
through it all, but I was basically sent some of the evidence.
It's like there is evidence of some
But there's also a lot of a lot of other lines in some of this
stuff that it's
It's so hard to have this conversation cuz I I do understand
how some people when it when they hear this laid out and I probably
need to look into it more,
I don't want to I don't want to invalidate anybody who's suffered
any kind of violence,
right? I I don't want to do that. I'm just saying that like the
level to which we know and the numbers
are quite questionable for this case,
And that it does seem undeniable. I will say it's undeniable,
in my opinion,
that it was blown up past what truly happened
in order to dehumanize people and make it less likely for people
to push back and say no, don't go in, don't kill a bunch of people.
I I think that's kind of that's bordering to me on just being
facts, right? The Hamas massacre hoax, the same hoax that was
used by Western media, the US government, and the Israeli government
to justify genocide. Now, this would come down to has Ethan talked
about this? And Ethan doesn't say when he's talked about this,
and Noah doesn't actually say when he's talked about it either.
He just says he has. So, that'll come down to whether or not
Ethan has talked about it and used those words.
Okay. Basically Canadian Corner, yeah. And unfortunately, at
this point, the Israeli government are the least trustworthy
government in the region. Sucks to suck, man. Okay, the third
defamatory statement is Samson's false factual assertion that
Ethan spreads overt misinformation.
Okay. Just straight-up lies about Hezbollah and Ansar Allah or
the Houthis in order to delegitimize their struggle against Israel's
genocide. He cites baseless claims from the Saudi state propaganda
outlets to attack the Houthis. He also cites documentary about
Ansar Allah, which he uses as proof
uh as proof of the claim that they brought back slavery when
the documentary wasn't even about the Houthis. It was about the
Yemeni government before the Houthi takeover. The third defamatory
statement. Okay, this is These are all going to be factual claims,
right? Like, if this is just a fact that he lied about this,
Dude, they're not even saying Shouldn't they be saying what part
is the lie for
Cuz some of these like these are multiple statements. What's
the defamatory lie? Is that Ethan spreads overt misinformation?
That's an opinion. Just straight-up lies about Hezbollah and
Ansar Allah or the Houthis in order to delegitimize their struggle
against Israel's genocide.
So, depending on whether or not these are factual, this would
be like another opinion, right?
I He's not even doing like a good job. Are they arguing They
have to be arguing damages cuz this isn't a crime. When Loader
Box went over the video originally, he said Ethan took an L on
the documentary thing. Okay, well, then I don't I literally don't
understand how this could be defamatory. The fifth defamatory
statement is Samson's false factual assertion that Ethan cites
sources that contradict his own claims directly, such as the
UN report he claims proves the Hamas massacre allegation, which
the report itself
These are the things he's saying are defamatory. What about them
is defamatory is what I need to know, and it's not really saying,
and many of these are compound statements.
Saying multiple things.
The sixth defamatory statement is Samson's false factual assertion
that he, Ethan, spends 20 minutes in the
smearing a 19-year-old survivor of the US-backed Saudi genocide
in Yemen as a terrorist and zero with zero Sorry, as a terrorist
with zero credible evidence. The sixth defamatory statement.
Okay. Oh, he goes into each of these Okay, hold on. Let's
Oh, this is going to be good. Oh, I didn't realize it was going
to be this delicious. He does go into the more.
I'm excited. First, Samson holds himself out as an expert in
the Israel-Palestine conflict. Second, to buttress his
Is it imprimatur?
of authority on the subject, Samson will inundate his audience
with a kaleidoscope of citations, most of which he misrepresents
or are wholly unreliable. This is done intentionally, so Samson
can exploit his audience's low level of knowledge on the same
subject matter because he knows why he knows they will not research
his citations on their own. Third, Samson's tone is serious and
earnest, which is reflected in the language he employs. Tho-
These are some of the reasons why Samson intended and his audience
perceived the defamatory statements as assertions of
Oh, uh-oh.
Although most people, you know, usually when you hear this kind
of rhetoric, you would take it as an opinion, but actually because
he perceives it because he presents himself as an expert, that's
why it's like a fact. I Sorry, that's not how it works. I just
don't
There could be experts. Just cuz somebody went to university
for international relations or something, that doesn't mean they
get to declare it a genocide. It's still an opinion.
What the Okay.
The first defamatory statement As mentioned, the first defamatory
statement is comprised of the thumbnail in the defamatory video
and its title. The first defamatory statement is subject to being
proven true or false. Merriam-Webster Dictionary defines the
verb to back as to support by material or moral assistance.
The term genocide is
The term Um Citing the dictionary,
so we'll we'll just take these as as a
Uh I I will just say Ethan Klein says it's a genocide in Israel,
and basically Noah Samson says, "Through your actions, you are
intentionally
Uh I believe he thinks intentionally. He might even make that
claim. Not directly, but intentionally supporting the state of
Israel.
Supporting the status quo, not letting things move to where this
genocide could stop. Whether Ethan provided material moral support
to genocidal acts by Israel is subject to being proven true or
false. I mean,
Uh you could say this is the way it is, but he is not Like, he
explicitly The problem is, okay,
this is an argument you could try to make, but it's a argument
to make because it goes down to what he was thinking and what
other people perceive it as. And Noah gives his reasoning for
doing it. So, saying like, "Well, actually Noah was trying to
explicitly argue that under the Webster Dictionary definition
of this, that Ethan Klein provided material moral support for
genocidal acts in Israel." He's not arguing that. He literally
says why he thinks Ethan Klein is backing a genocide. It's a
manufacturing consent
And that's not what they're addressing at all. Like, the problem
is he literally lays it out. So, no reasonable person could think
this is his reason that he's making a factual argument based
on the dictionary definitions.
It's goofy, man. It's goofy.
As demonstrated in paragraphs 16 to 18, Ethan does not and has
not supported Israel's genocide of the Palestinian people whatsoever.
To the contrary, he has expressly stated the opposite and supported
numerous charities dedicated to helping Palestinians.
Sams- Samson knew the first defamatory statement was false. Yeah,
I know this is not even remotely addressing the argument made
in the video. Ethan expresses repeated condemnation of Israel's
treatment of
I This is literally not engaging at all with the arguments made
in the video. He is super lazy. I mean, moral You could say manufacturing
consent is moral assistance. You could say that. I don't know
if that's like moral assistance I'm I'm thinking he takes to
mean like showing support for.
Right? It's like indirectly showing support for. But that's the
argument he's making. He's you're indirectly supporting this.
and then he's just going to say, "Look at all these places where
me or the defamatory video shows two brief clips." Oh, Samson
engages similar conduct. This is all going to be irrelevant for
Mudahar, but apparently his video about Mudahar is defamatory.
Defamatory for Chuck E. Tom. Nobody cares. The first defamatory
statement also falsely portrayed Loader Box, who's Lebanese,
as supporting Israel's genocide of the Palestinian people. After
Loader Box criticized Sam- Samson's sloppy research, he repeated
misrepresentations of sources and overt misinformation in the
defamatory video.
Samson retaliated by including Loader Box in the thumbnail for
the defamatory
Is that real? Wait, hold on. Am I reading that correctly that
Loader Box criticized the video and then Noah Samson went and
edited the video by adding Loader Box to the thumbnail? That's
That's like kind of a funny response. I >> I don't agree
with it, but it's kind of a funny response.
Samson also expressed his desire to falsely paint Ethan as supporting
the genocide of Palestinians for clout financial reasons.
In the In the defamatory video, Samson states, "I think many
of you can probably also help out with that because most of you
have smartphones and cameras and TikTok. So, go ahead and start
posting about it. Spread the word. Aside from being a morally
good thing to do, it's also becoming sustainable, you know? It's
algorithmically viable. The Ethan Klein crash out industrial
complex is booming."
Okay, to desire to falsely paint No, he thinks it's true.
No, he thinks it's true. That's way different. But I I wasn't
sure what he meant. And so, he did encourages his whole fan base
to go and make clips of Ethan Klein crashing out and make fun
of Ethan Klein for supporting genocide in this exact way, right?
Okay, I just don't see Like, this comes down again materially
to whether or not it's a def- defamatory statement to say these
people backed a genocide in a thumbnail and a title. If Trust
me, if you could be held for defa- if you be held liable for
defamation in a thumbnail and title, oh boy are some YouTubers
IN TROUBLE. OH BOY, WE'RE going to get We're going to be It's
going to be a bad day for YouTubers, isn't it? Clickbaiting with
your thumbnails and titles? Defamatory?
Oh, no. Anyway, I also don't think I think even if you took this
as a legitimate statement,
that still wouldn't be defamatory, but anyway, we continue. Samson's
statement that it was algorithmically viable to falsely state
that Ethan supported the genocide of Palestinians was correct.
To date, the defamatory video is Samson's second most viewed
video with nearly 1.5 million views. In contrast,
the video he made after the defamatory video entitled defamatory
video entitled Manufacturing Consent for Genocide received approximately
154,000 views, 10% of what the defamatory video received. In
a video defendants published on May 15th, 2025, Samson admitted
that he included Ethan in the thumbnail so the defamatory video
would garner more views.
Okay, that makes it sound like he didn't actually have this criticism
of Ethan, but he clearly did. So, in fact, that's probably the
person he's most strongly criticized. So, a little misleading
right here, I'd say.
Feel like a little misleading. Further, Samson used the second
the second through sixth defamatory statement to support his
false false to support his false factual assertion that Ethan
supported a genocide, which each of which are discussed below.
The second and fifth defamatory statements. Both the second and
fifth defamatory statements falsely assert that Ethan spread
the Hamas mass hoax or Hamas mass
To support these assertions, Samson falsely asserts that Ethan
misrepresented the contents of the March 4th, 2024 report from
the United Nations. Paragraph 84 of the UN report states, "Overall,
based on the totality of information gathered from multiple and
independent sources at different locations, there are reasonable
grounds to believe that the conflict-related violence occurred
at several locations across the Gaza periphery." Okay, so what
is the what is the actual evidence
And this this part I believe has been, like I said, I think debunked.
So, mass here meaning like
occurring everywhere en masse.
So, I'd say probably uh God, where do you put the line there?
With mass hysteria,
if you have a crowd of 100 people,
and let's say five let's say five people of 100
suffer from hysteria. Is that mass hysteria? It might be. I'm
trying to think of how mass is used. To me, it feels like it's
majority,
but I don't know. I'm trying to think of like how you would use
that in a colloquial sense.
Cuz I I do think uh it's tough.
>> The issue is is there seems to have been a intentional
inserted effort to paint it as like from
there was orders to Israeli women.
That was how it was painted in the
And so it's tough for me to like to totally be against people
saying like mass means coordinated or to imply that.
So, paragraph 85 of the UN report states, "With regards to hostages,
the mission team found clear and convincing information that
some of the hostages taken to Gaza have been subjected to various
forms of conflict-related violence and has reasonable grounds
to believe such violence is ongoing."
Is this saying
Is this saying violence? Interesting.
Paragraph 86 of the UN report states, "The mission team was unable
to establish the prevalence of sexual violence and concludes
the overall magnitude, scope, and specific attribution of these
violations require a fully fledged investigation. A comprehensive
investigation would enable the information base to be expanded
in locations which the mission team was not able to visit and
to build the required trust with the survivors/victims of the
conflict-related violence who may be reluctant to come forward
at this point at all." Okay. That seems kind of important, right?
Was unable to establish the prevalence of violence. So, if you
are if you are saying that mass occurred
in a report that says the mission team was unable to establish
the prevalence of violence,
does that not feel like that is wrong? Do we not feel like that
is wrong?
That seems to be the argument, right? The issue is the term mass.
Well, sorry, my issue isn't the term mass, right? Ethan's issue
right now is that Noah Samson is calling it mass rapes and calling
it a hoax that it's mass rapes. So, that was Noah's issue, and
now Ethan is saying that's a defamat saying saying that me saying
Hamas rap mass rape allegation or something is a
is is false or misleading. That's defamatory.
Cuz this is I assume he's going to argue that this is true, that
mass rapes did occur. So, we'll keep
The aforementioned paragraphs make clear that there were numerous
instances of violence perpetrated by Hamas against Israelis at
several locations on October 7th. This is not in dispute. Rather,
further investigation was necessary to determine the overall
magnitude, scope, and specific attribution and of these numerous
acts of violence. There were numerous instances of violence perpetrated
by Hamas against Israelis. This is not in dispute. Rather, further
investigation was necessary to determine the overall magnitude,
scope, and specific attribution.
Samson expressly misrepresented the constant contents of the
UN report to knowingly and intentionally paint Ethan as lying
about Hamas engaging in numerous acts of violence. What did Ethan
say? That's the problem, right?
What did Ethan say is what I Is it the the content nuke?
Let's we got to go to the content nuke, don't we? that we have
actually gotten verifiable evidence on. Beyond that, the the
systematized mass that Hamas dealt on October 7th, not a single
bit of that has been verified, and people still run with it over
So, unfortunately for Ethan, this is going to be systematized
mass rape. If he cast out on this statement from Hassad, then
that is probably what Noah is talking
>> over and over and over again. many young people who
were simply
attending a music festival.
Women were >> Okay, hold on. Wait. Before this, is there
some some speech from Ethan?
Okay, fine. He likes Hamas. He watches their propaganda, but
he's not going to deny the the violent that took place. That
is way beyond the pale. There is one That's a really funny edit.
That's a really I'm sorry. That's really
>> that we have actually gotten verifiable evidence on.
Beyond that, the the systematized mass that Hamas dealt on October
7th, not a single bit of that has been verified. >> getting
once again doing rapes. violence after endurance for me even
quickly left
>> Gum Goldsteen quickly left to go from believe all women
to pics or it didn't happen. The vast majority of people, if
not all, who were were murdered on the spot, obviously. >> Gum
Goldsteen not all Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
This is Hold on. He references Screams of Silence, which Noah
is saying is now discredited.
Is Screams of Silence discredited? in Gaza as well in a new documentary
by Sheryl Sandberg, Screams Before Silence. In new footage, a
Gum reveals that assault and was a regular component of the life
as a hostage in Gaza. Hassan, maybe you would like to call her
a liar.
Okay, so this is literally spreading atrocity propaganda mass
hoax,
right? This is this is what is spreading the mass hoax is like
there's this systemic thing. Oh, it was a part of daily life
living in Gaza. Everybody was
No, I think I think this was basically done with like really
the I mean, we go back to the allegation of Noah Samson. It's
going to come down to the factual matter here. So, Ethan spread
this,
He spread that documentary.
So, Samson expressly misrepresented the contents of the UN report
to paint Ethan as lying about acts in new Hamas engaging in numerous
acts of violence. Well, actually he says you spread this. >> He
shares the Hamas mass rape hoax, the same hoax that was used
by the Western media, the US government, and the Israeli government
to justify a genocide. He cites the same sources that these parties
cite when they go on stage to legitimize more military
That seems
That seems like you know, you could argue that's coming down
to, but then who is who is Noah Samson defaming? If he's Is he
defaming Kamala Not Kamala Harris. Is he defaming Sheryl Sandberg
and the documentary? Or is he defaming Ethan? Cuz it's pretty
obvious in this case that Ethan did cite this, and that's what
Noah Samson is
I don't know how you get away from that. Okay, Samson knew he
had to misrepresent the UN report because of the repeated lionization
of Hamas as a heroic resistance. To acknowledge this violence
would contradict his narrative and demonstrate he supports assault.
Again, he did the it was the mass hoax thing,
That it was like a regular like systemic part of life there.
Ryan Grim went over the issues with the New York Times report.
Okay.
We could We could go into this later, but I do think that Ethan's
like messing this up, actually. That this this is not the argument
Noah is making,
right? It's not entirely based on the UN report. There is I think
references to the UN report in here, but this is uh he's This
documentary is the first piece of information, it seems like.
Oh, yeah, he talks about Screams of Silence and stuff, too.
There's like a whole section on it. We watched it.
Yikes, man. Ryan just says that it's fake, no? Yeah, well, I'm
guessing he does. I'd like to see the reason he says it's fake.
Anyway, we continue on with the lawsuit. Oh my
Lots to get through, guys. So,
where were we here?
So, indeed, immediately after the second defamatory statement,
second and fifth about the mass hoax, Samson cites materials
he claims support his assertion that the Hamas mass hoax was
used by the Western media, the US government, and the Israeli
government to justify a genocide. The materials he cited, however,
only discuss conflict-related violence in general and not just
October 7th and did not discuss Israel's actions in Gaza whatsoever.
Oh, this is so disingenuous. I hope I I assume lawyers could
see or sorry, like judges can see through this. It's like it's
literally the all lives matter argument, right? Like a black
dude gets killed by police unjustifiably, and people go out to
protest, and they say black lives matter, and you run up and
you start yelling all lives matter, and they say, "Hey, you're
kind of taking away from the thing going on here." Right? You're
kind of running defense for the people who did this bad thing.
You're like, "No, why won't you have just a conversation that
all lives matter? Why Why do you have to make me feel like I
don't matter at all?"
Brother, this is not about you.
You know what I mean?
I always think I think the dude, the all lives matter thing is
like such a filter. I feel like it's the
Like you're you're pretending you don't
what you're doing and how it affects a certain situation. Dude,
I It's just very goofy to me every time.
The third defamatory statement.
The third defamatory statement asserts that Ethan spread overt
misinformation and straight-up lies,  "straight-up lies"
about Hezbollah and Ansar Allah, aka the Houthis, in the content
nuke. In the nuke, by the way, can somebody if you have a moment,
could My Lord, maybe if you have if you're at your computer,
could you just find me Luna Boxes section reacting to the nuke
where he talks about this stuff, the document the documentary?
I want to see that.
Anyway, in the nuke Ethan pointed out the following facts about
Hezbollah. It engaged in terrorism resulting in the deaths of
thousands of civilians. Okay? It orchestrated the assassination
of the Lebanese Prime Minister, Rafic Hariri.
Okay? It hijacked airplanes. It fired 15,000 rockets in civilian
areas. It intervened in the Syrian Civil War to aid the dictator
Bashar al-Assad, which resulted in the death of hundreds of thousands
of civilians. Six, its former leader Hassan Nasrallah made numerous
anti-Semitic and genocidal statements against and seven, it initiated
the most recent round of fighting on October 8th, not Israel,
which resulted in 100 Israelis killed and over 200,000
I don't recall him saying any of those were lies. In fact, I
actually don't
what lies he accused him of spreading about Hezbollah. I actually
don't recall. I remember the Ansar Allah stuff. I don't remember
the Hezbollah
despite asserting that despite asserting that Ethan spread overt
misinformation and straight-up lies about Hezbollah, Samson failed
to identify, let alone prove, any statement Ethan made in the
nuke about Hezbollah was that was false.
So, that is interesting cuz I don't even know that
Yeah, okay. So, there there you go. I was actually right that
he didn't actually even give something that he disagreed with
about Hezbollah.
Samson failed to do so because he knew that Ethan's statements
were true. In the nuke, Ethan pointed out the following facts
with the Houthis. They recruit child soldiers. They shell civilians.
They block aid to civilians. They ruin agricultural land with
mines. So, all these things you said that were true don't don't
you try to go over the thing that you think he's talking about.
Why are you saying Yeah, if you
Sure. Leaving alone that like all these are facts. It's just
the easiest way to get a lie through is to say a bunch of true
things around it, right? If I present myself as an authority
and I say true thing, true thing, true thing, true thing, lie,
true thing, true thing, true thing, that's the easiest way If
I just go lie, lie, lie, lie, lie, lie, lie, then it's very easy
to show that I'm not
Right? They ruin agricultural land with mines. Wasn't number
four directly from a Saudi propaganda paper? Possibly.
That could be what he's talking about. They captured the ship
Galaxy Leader in international waters, not in any waters, and
the ship was not destined to or traveling from Israel. And 10,
they took the crew of the Galaxy Leader, who were not Israeli
hostage.
Despite asserting that Ethan spread overt misinformation and
straight-up lies about the Houthis, Samson fails to address,
let alone refute, any of the aforementioned statements Ethan
made about the Houthis. Samson failed to do so because he knew
that Ethan's statements were true and had no evidence to contradict
those statements because none exists.
Oh, right here. >> Number seven. In his video, Ethan spreads
overt misinformation, just straight-up lies, about Hezbollah
and Ansar Allah or the Houthis in order to delegitimize their
struggle against Israel's genocide. He cites baseless claims
from Saudi state propaganda outlets to Houthis restore slavery
in Yemen. Okay. So, he's saying this is baseless. This is not
like true. Now,
I will say is the argument something like Houthis like basically
in Yemen slavery already existed and they allowed it to
That'd be funny. But so baseless, this is what he identifies
as a lie. So, Ethan Klein said, "What?" Wait, did he just leave
They recruit child soldiers. They shell civilians. They blockade.
Well, there's the lie right there. I just found it a lie that
he identified. Did he not say anything about slavery?
Oh, I almost forgot the most fun one. They brought back slavery.
You [cheering] think the Houthis Ansar [screaming] Allah is doing
what So, this is literally exactly what he's referring to and
he's saying this is a
So, if if these things are false and if they're based on the
government before or cuz I think that's what he said this this
was based on the government before. Right? If this stuff is just
lies, it is not the government the Houthis overthrew at slaves.
Well, that's I understand that's Noah's argument. So, it'll just
come down to the material facts there and I could have sworn
that Luna Box himself had gone through this video in this part
and realized that Ethan this up. So, when Ethan's lawsuit says,
"Well, actually, like it does feel like Ethan is doing this because
he is feeling a lot of pressure. He's feeling like he's sort
of cast out from a lot of social circles and so he's doing this
Like this this feels like
to me
he's not really actually arguing against the video. He's like
trying to make this look as
as good for content creators as he can.
Right? Like this is just trying to make it look good for content
creators. I can see the lie that Samson's pointing out
And it's just not included. Or maybe Oh, wait. What Hold on.
So, you just gave a bunch of
Why why do this? Is this actually a good legal strategy? Is just
to like flood the zone with totally useless
Are there are there lawyers or judges who appreciate this? Like
just flooding the zone with totally worthless
Well, actually, I know you're mad at me and you're mad at me
for lying, but here's some true stuff I said.
Why would that matter when the lies are the things that are being
focused on?
I just don't get it. And no, judges hate it. Well, I don't know
if you're a judge if you're a lawyer, Dogan Damon, but it says
that Ethan spread misinformation and straight-up lies about Hezbollah
and Ansar Allah. I So, I haven't seen anything about Hezbollah
specifically. So, that could be the part where actually, you
know, you have to take back the thing about Hezbollah. Despite
asserting that Ethan spread all these things, he fails to address,
let alone refute, any of these statements.
Instead, Samson solely focused on Ethan's assertion that the
Houthis engaged in slavery. Samson does not provide evidence
refuting Ethan's assertion. Rather, Samson tries to attack the
two sources cited in the nuke to support the assertion that the
Houthis engaged in slavery. An article entitled exclusive Houthis
restore slavery in Yemen from Al Al-Sharq
English version's here and documentary Al Jazeera World entitled
Slavery in Yemen. Al Jazeera documentary. Samson makes the assertion
that Al-Sharq Al-Awsat or Al Al-Awsat Al-Awsat. Al-Sharq Al-Awsat
article contains baseless claims from Saudi state propaganda
outlets without supporting any supporting evidence.
Samson's conclusory assertions are false. The Al-Sharq Al-Awsat
article cited receiving information from one, sources close to
the Houthis, two, several local reports, three, Yemeni activists,
four, lawyers in Yemen, and five, a civilian who worked for a
pro-Houthi tribal leader. Further, the United States State State
Department cited the Al-Sharq Al-Awsat
article in its 2022 country reports on human rights practices,
Yemen, for the prop for the proposition that the newspaper Al-Sharq
Al-Awsat reported in 2019 that prominent Houthis held more than
1,800 citizens as slaves and servants who worked in their residences
and places of work.
Whoa. Oh, he said Hezbollah is responsible for killing more Arabs
than the IDF. Half a million was the number he gave.
Oh, I'm guessing that the IDF has killed more than half a million
Arabs.
Would that be the argument back? I actually don't know how many
people Hezbollah killed in the civil in the Syrian Civil War.
I know it was plenty
I got no real clue there, okay? So, it'll come down just to basically
how well Noah could prove this out and basically that he could
have this opinion reasonably, right? I'm not going to keep reading
that name. Holy That's throwing me off. So, Samson makes the
assertion that Ethan misrepresents the Al Jazeera documentary
because it was released before the Houthi takeover of Yemen.
This is false. The Al Jazeera documentary was released in September
on September 10th, 2014. The Houthis controlled parts of Yemen
as early as March 2011 with the Battle of Sa'dah.
the Battle of Sanaa, which cemented Houthi control over northern
Yemen, began prior to the release of Al the Al Jazeera documentary.
So, the obvious question here is when was the documentary filmed,
right? Why would the release date of the documentary mean anything?
Why why would the release date of the documentary be a big deal?
Could anybody help me out? Indeed, the Houthis engagement in
human trafficking is well documented in 2020 This doesn't matter.
In In 2023, an independent Yemeni human rights organization,
Mwatana, found that the Houthis forcibly recruited African migrants
and deployed them to the front lines of conflict zones, then
refused to pay them. That is not slavery. Dude. Is Donald Is
Donald Trump a slaver? Is he actually a slaver? I didn't know
that. I didn't realize being fraudulent made you a slaver. That
implies So, if I would say if they said, "We need to get paid"
and then they held a gun to your head and said, "Keep fighting.
You're not allowed to leave." then that could be slavery.
But if it's if it's literally that they Well, I guess Houthi
forcibly recruited. Sure, forcibly recruited, then refused to
pay them. I missed the forcibly word. Yeah, I missed the forcibly
word. My No, you're right. You're right. I'll back it up and
say forcibly recruited or caused them to like force them to stay.
Yeah, that's Well, human trafficking I mean, you might call it
something different than slavery that it's not like some sort
of understood arrangement.
But it's like it's all of the bad things of slavery. It's like
slavery with uh it's like a little bit worse than just like regular
indentured servitude or um chattel slavery.
Further, the independent published an article reporting on the
Houthis engaging in trafficking supporting or supporting by statements
from Yemeni victims, lawyers, and human rights
So, again, I unfortunately for
Unfortunately for Ethan, you have to be incredibly precise
when you are trying to sue somebody for defamation. So, what
did what did he say specifically about this? It is
that these two sources are bad, right?
So, if one of them is from I guess before the the took over,
like if if that's when it was shot,
then that's not a lie. And if the other thing is basically if
you could show that it's a Saudi propaganda outlet,
if you had some evidence of like Saudi funding, I do think that's
nearly enough to discredit this article. Oh, learn about Saudi
too. I don't remember him making them. I remember the Houthis
because with the Houthis what they do is they just try to write
off that
on the slaves that were kept in Houthi
of their senior officials because it was a Saudi newspaper even
though it's been vetted and approved by the
uh US State Department as well. I It sucks cuz I
you'll never convince people on opposite sides of this ever,
right?
Like I don't know. I I literally don't know what to say.
It's so tough
cuz I understand exactly people like, well, Saudi are an ally.
The Houthis are not an ally. Saudis were literally fighting against
the Houthis.
There's every reason to believe that they would lie about the
Houthis or lie about this specific thing, right? Yeah, that I
know the Houthis suck, but it's just like I understand people
who don't want to believe like, oh, well, Saudi
Saudi government I'm sorry, the Saudi Saudi newspaper and the
State Department. I'm sure the Houthis are terrible people, okay?
I'm sure they're like Sorry, they're very different morally than
us. They've got a totally different moral
system than us due to the world they grew up in or something,
okay? But I
I do tend to believe that like the slavery would exist there.
The thing is is Noah basically says that the sources are bad
and I'm not sure that you could really get him on defamation
for saying the sources are bad there.
That's all. That's all cuz again, when you're attacking somebody
when you're suing somebody for defamation, you have to be very
precise and I'm not sure that that rises to the level. Maybe
it does. Maybe that and by the way, we're leaving out the part
with the Hezbollah thing. You said he told multiple lies about
I wonder if he's found multiple lies about Hezbollah and it just
didn't fit in the video or if he just, you know, was riffing
and said it and can't back it up. Be hard to tell. Okay.
And again, >> else here? The funny thing is is like there's
a bit in here where he says, what did he say? It was something
along the lines of like, you might not think the US State Department
is a credible source, but it's going to be up to a an American
judge and jury. Oh, no.
Yeah, we're talking about the Houthis. Let's start there. It
says you focus on solely on the assertion that the Houthis engaged
in slavery. You do not, however, prefer facts refusing the assertion.
Rather, you attempt to impeach the credibility of the sources
relied upon by Ethan. For example, you attack the article in
the exclusive, "Houthis restore slavery in Yemen" from Asharq
Al-Awsat, the English version. The article itself refers to receiving
information from sources close to the group, several local reports,
Yemeni activists, a member of the Lawyers Syndicate in Yemen,
and a civilian who works for a pro-Houthi tribal leader in Saada.
Other than your blind assertion that the article contains baseless
claims from Saudi state propaganda outlets, you cite no evidence
refusing the substance of the article or the sources it relied
upon. Wow. You mean you can't just say the source is bad, therefore
wow. It's so ironic that these guys also they don't trust Saudi
Arabian newspaper, which again is fair, Saudi Arabia, but they're
okay to cite Al Jazeera. Like Al Jazeera is the state media of
a dictatorship in Qatar that literally has like forced labor.
But like slavery We trust So, I understand that, but I I So,
maybe it's a little different. I understand it's state-run media
with with Al Jazeera.
Is what's Al Jazeera's track record?
Can anybody Can anybody give me Al Jazeera's track track record?
Because to me it feels like with Al Jazeera,
they've got like actually quite a good track record over time.
I know a lot of people when I was like younger, people like really
respected Al Jazeera and it was like I I remember, dude, when
I was like really young playing World of Warcraft for the first
time.
Uh people would tell me you should read Al Jazeera. I never did
it, but they're like, you should read Al Jazeera. I just see
like the Arab writing. I'm like, why are you linking me this?
They're like, you should read this. This is where the real news
comes from. I'm like, okay, I no idea what you're talking about.
But then I I realized that like people respected Al Jazeera's
reporting for a long time. As long as it's not about Qatar, it's
unbiased or it feels not not that bad. Okay. Yeah, I I could
see it being that way.
I thought they generally like it's like, yeah, you can state-run
media, but that's cuz like in Qatar, it's basically going to
be tons of state-owned enterprise and I thought the idea was
like, hey, this is going to be our thing. We're the people who
do the like Arabic news network that's respected for how accurate
it is,
Like we are going to be the people who get it right cuz we don't
want to have the reputation of being like some state-owned propaganda
outlet that stole the stories up,
I thought that was like the general ethos of Al Jazeera.
But I guess if you if you it is also, you know, state-funded
media, so That's
Weird. And like I would Yeah, I would The other thing is if one
state-funded media, but it's attacking a purely on the lines
of like enemy-friend distinction,
the Houthis, I wouldn't trust anything like, yeah, the Qataris
reporting on
what was happening in Iran. Like Al Jazeera reporting on what
was happening in Iran like right after, let's say, a month from
now. I don't know that I would trust Al Jazeera even in that
case. I'd be like, ah, well, maybe they have good reporting in
the area. I don't know. But it's like it's like a specific state
enemy that is they're actively fighting against at that exact
moment in time. Little weird. The United States State Department
cited the affirmation article in its 2022 country reports on
human rights practices in Yemen. The newspaper Asharq Al-Awsat
reported in 2019 that prominent Houthis held more than 1,800
citizens as slaves and servants who worked in their residences
and places of work. While you may may not While you may not consider
the State Department trustworthy,
it is highly unlikely a judge or jury will share your opinion,
particularly based on nothing more than blind assertions. That's
so funny. I know I got two comments saying, "They didn't cite
anyone, just unnamed sources." Compared to what? Have you read
How many reports have you read uh like inhuman practices in dictatorship-style
rule? Like what are you talking about? Should the victims or
the people involved like who are literally in danger of their
lives give their name and address? Their full box. There's nothing
wrong with an anonymous source. Like
even if it didn't cite certain things, surely wouldn't be harsh
on those standards. Um that's more to do with the totality because
because you know what, for me, and again, layperson, for me,
the fact that Noah said and did all this
in a video where he has a Ground News segment where he talks
about the importance of factual reliability and scrutinizing
sources and getting a non-partisan image of what's Like all
I I'll be honest.
I don't care about somebody not citing their sources
like in the video. If If somebody comes out and says like, you
lied about this and you refuse to like cite your argument, then
it's a problem. But in terms of like making an making a documentary
or or anything like a video essay flow, sometimes if you're setting
up like a a claim, you should show your sources. I didn't get
the feeling in the Noah Samson thing that I needed to see all
the sourcing there for some of the stuff he was saying. I'm like,
I understand what your argument is and if you're called on it,
I would expect you to produce, but for the sake of the argument
flowing and the video flowing, I don't care that you include
literally everything. Maybe you should include some sort of like
bibliography type of deal at the end showing how you set your
I would say that if you want to leave it out, you should probably
include something that allows people to go through it if they
want to. But I don't necessarily need it all to happen in the
video. Now, I would wonder what exactly what problems Noah had
with these things exactly other than, you know, this is Saudi
state propaganda and then I guess the the documentary thing seemed
like a bigger deal than I thought it would. >> just completely
forgoing those principles on every single claim. That's quite
funny. I don't know I don't know if it's quite funny. Now, I
don't know. I don't know if this Saudi article is credible or
not. I have no [__] idea because it's it's Saudi,
you know? Like They're not exactly like Is that not
Is that not I What but it isn't that sort of doing the same thing
kind of?
Joe, which is also a bro Isn't that basically what Noah said?
Consistent in that. The generally the state media. I don't even
know if that paper was state media. It might have been funded.
I don't know if it was state media. But generally the state media
of a dictatorship,
I'm generally not going to trust that. But I don't know if this
paper is state media. Do we know? Cuz it's funded by the state
is not the same as state But yeah, these people also cite Quds
News Network. They do, yeah.
It's owned by a Saudi royal. So, if it's owned by a Saudi royal,
that doesn't necessarily make it state media, but obviously doesn't
make it very partisan, so um
the thing I don't get is why do these people act like the Saudis
are the only people who have made this claim?
That's why I don't That's why I'm struggling to understand. Um
Well, I think he was basically arguing against Ethan Klein, which
again, I don't think in terms of Noah Samson being correct, I
don't necessarily think Noah Samson is like correct that the
Houthis are like a totally respectable, awesome group cuz he
does seem to say that in a in a heroic struggle. I don't I don't
think that. I don't feel that. But that wasn't really what his
argument was. His argument was that Ethan Klein was misrepresenting
them and using bad sources to do it.
And so, like I understand
that's a different argument than, oh, the Houthis are awesome.
He's not I I don't think he was trying to prove that the Houthis
were awesome. He was trying to say, you actually misrepresented
them, which I don't even know. It seems dicey that he did that
and also the whole Hezbollah thing. Do they know that the Saudis
are not the only ones We're basically done with this. No one
denies that the Houthis use child soldiers, okay? If you're a
leftist, the same kind of who call the American prison system
slavery, who call wage labor slavery all the time, they're not
going to say that child soldiers are a form of slavery.
Cuz no one denies that. We we know no one denies it because the
Houthis literally take pictures of their child soldiers and they
brag about it. Yeah, I should Obviously terrible.
Obviously terrible. I've got no defense of child soldiers.
Yeah, Houthis bad guys. Would not I I think Noah Samson saying,
"Oh, they're in a heroic struggle and they're doing every I think
the Houthis, you know, it's a whole idea of like you have to
have some principles cuz if you only have goals and you think,
you know, the ends justify the means, you will eventually do
something monstrous, right? Eventually you will do something
That's why you have to have principles like principles against
having child soldiers. Seems like a good one to start You know
what I'm saying? And I don't think And there are some things
that I'm even willing to say cuz I'm I'm partial to the argument
sometimes when people say, "Well, you didn't grow up in those
conditions. You don't know what it's like, so how can you judge
these people?" I'm partial to that argument basically everywhere,
right? Except around like a couple
Like is a weapon of war or child soldiers, right?
But for most things you could you could make that argument to
me and I'm like, well, I will soften my judgment of the people
over that thing. But like child
as a weapon of war or as a punishment or torture, it's like there
are certain things where I'm just like, "Nah, nah, we don't need
that at all." Nah, there's really no excuse. There's There's
never any excuse. Not to mention, this is Plenty of countries
groom children to be soldiers. Even that is less disgusting than
actually having like a 12-year-old holding an AK. Let's be real.
This is from an independent human rights organization that's
gone around Yemen and interviewed witnesses and victims and things
like that. And they have a quite a long report on human rights
abuses in Yemen by both parties, by the government and by the
Houthis and also by some independent actors. Uh So I I It makes
me wonder like are are Ethiopian migrants, for example, who have
been victimized by the Houthis, are they Saudi propagandists?
Back to the article. I'm This is probably Ethan's best chance
at like having some sort of claim, it seems like. Feels like
it's the best
I said I don't really see any Up to this point I've been like
everything's This is terrible. This is a god forsaken like lawsuit.
No shot. This one where it's like the especially the Hezbollah
thing where I don't think there was any pushback on that at all
even though he said he was even though Noah said he was lying.
It will ultimately come down to was Noah, you know, what is his
reasoning that he can present in the lawsuit? So he will be able
to go and do this and if he can give a good reasoning, I still
think he's probably safe, but Hey. Okay. Do you think Destiny's
worried Ethan will sue him for claiming he his children? No.
Ethan Klein only sues or fights with people he thinks are weaker
than him. He is a cowardly
He will never fight with somebody bigger than him, stronger than
him in any possible way. He will always cower in the shadows
and pick fights with people he's bigger than and try to beat
them down. If Ethan will never pick a fight with somebody who
can hurt him back,
And the second he realizes somebody can hurt him back, he will
drop that fight instantly because he is a with no morals, doesn't
care about saying somebody saying he his kids. All he cares about
is beating up smaller people and looking strong for doing it.
That's all he cares about, okay? No morals, no principles, nothing.
Destiny could go live on his stream every single day and say
Ethan Klein his and Ethan Klein would do nothing about it cuz
Ethan Klein got slap he got slapped by Destiny
and he knows not to with him. He knows he can't win that fight.
He doesn't want that smoke.
Ethan Klein, Destiny pulled his pocket out and Ethan Klein is
holding it and following him around, okay? That's that's who
Ethan Klein is. He's He's the guy who holds the pocket in prison,
all right? All right. Now that you understand that, the fourth
defamatory statements. The fourth defamatory statement falsely
asserts that Ethan denied the Nakba to legitimize Israelis' colonization.
Nowhere does Samson identify one, what Ethan said that denied
the Nakba, two, how those points were debunked, and three, how
these talking points legitimize Israeli colonation or colonization.
I've seen a video on this, so this is going to be about how Ethan
essentially compares the Nakba to the Israeli pogroms that caused
people to migrate back to Israel when it's totally like minimizing
the Nakba overall. Yeah, okay, so
That one is this video, I'm pretty sure. Okay, this might be
the guy. Basically, it's like you're taking like 20, 30 years
of of people remigrating to Sorry, migrating to Israel over time
and comparing it to the Nakba, it happening like almost immediately.
So I don't know if people talk People don't really talk about
this.
One day before the Nakba, people don't know. What happened one
day before the Nakba? Palestinians were living at home? What?
>> Palestinians were living at home? And you know what
else happened? Egypt, Syria, Lebanon,
all invaded Israel to kill everybody there. The invasion was
a response to the ongoing ethnic cleansing of Palestinian Nakba
and the rejection of the declaration of independence of Israel.
It was the
Arab armies that told the Palestinians to leave. Arab leaders
urged people to stay. A lot of the Palestinians who were told
to to leave and come back never got to come back home. Why? A
lot of >> This looks so bad now looking at what like looking
at what Israel's doing to all the homes in Lebanon, what they
did to all the homes in Gaza. This looks so bad. It's like, "Why
didn't they GET TO GO BACK HOME?" WELL, poisoning the wells,
blowing up all the homes. I wonder why they didn't get to go
back home. I wonder. >> Palestinians did stay in Israel
and those people are citizens. We can continue on with the reading
of the
lawsuit. Geez. Okay.
Falsely asserts Ethan denied the Nakba to to legitimize Israelis'
colonization.
colonation colonization. Jesus. I'm having a rough time reading.
Now, we need to go here. Nakba video. No. Yeah, Nakba Nakba
Okay. We need to go and hear what >> Gaza civil registry,
meaning that every single member of their bloodline has been
killed. Nor does he mention that the mass slaughter of these
innocent civilians has been intentional. Israel has a long history
of intentionally targeting Palestinian civilians for slaughter.
This dates back to the Nakba, the ethnic cleansing of over 700,000
Palestinians from their land in 19 documentary about Ansar Allah,
which he uses as proof of the claim that they brought back slavery
when the documentary wasn't even about the Houthis, it was about
the Yemeni government before the Houthi takeover. He spreads
long debunked Nakba denialist talking points, talking points
that have been used for decades to legitimize Israeli colonization
of Palestine. Ethan So again, Ethan has to be precise.
No Noah Samson doesn't say you denied the Nakba. He says you
spread Nakba denialist talking points to basically manufacture
consent for the initial colonization of Israel.
sites sources that contradict his own claims directly, such as
the UN report he claims proves the Hamas mass allegation. There's
a UN report that can Okay, so that's a little different. So falsely
asserts Ethan denied the Nakba to legitimize Israelis' colonization.
That is not what happened. That's a misreading of what happened.
He says you Nakba denialist talking points. Now, that's an example
where he doesn't actually cite it. He doesn't actually say how
that went down and what that looked like. But that's almost okay
because we all saw or I I think a lot of people were aware of
this Overzealous video where Ethan was doing this. And it's not
just in the content Duke, right?
So again, I do think like you have to be pretty specific and
pretty
tight when you're trying to do it a defamation lawsuit and it's
very it's very sloppy.
Okay. Nowhere does Samson identify one, what Ethan said that
denied the Nakba, two, how those points were debunked, and three,
how those talk These talking points legitimize Israeli colonation
colonization.
Instead, Samson shows a screenshot from a video by George
aka Bad Empanada
entitled Nakba Denier Expulsion Liar Content Duke destroyed the
Bad Empanada video with the text debunked here by Bad Empanada.
Oh, and the B video. Okay.
Bad Empanada has a notorious reputation for his full-throated
support of violence and terrorism against Israel and Israelis,
particularly October 7th. You're not going to You're not going
to be able to say Bad Empanada is bad to try to contend with
the argument that he's presenting. Did you Did you do things
to downplay the Nakba? Cuz by the way, if you downplayed the
Nakba in any way,
the argument already hits. That downplaying of the Nakba is quite
literally like is quite literally running defense for colonization
of
By definition. So So you did I I've watched the talking points
I've Sorry, I've watched the um the video from Overzealous. You
did downplay the Nakba. You did try to liken it to Israelis Sorry,
to people being prosecuted persecuted all over the Middle East
and eventually migrating back to Israel. It's not the same thing.
It's not anywhere near like as temporarily like tight as constrained.
It With the Nakba it all happened at once. It's way different,
okay?
All right.
So I I I don't know why I don't know why Bad Empanada being a
bad person
is relevant to the lawsuit. But anyway, he spreads intentional
falsehoods and misinformation about his enemies, including harassing
and doxing them. That's true.
Probably irrelevant to the lawsuit. At the top of Bad Empanada's
hit list are Ethan and Hila. Samson is well aware of Bad Empanada's
extreme antagonism towards Ethan, Israel, and Israelis due to
Samson's close friendship with Bad Empanada. Indeed, it is highly
likely that Bad Empanada played a substantial role in the creation
of the defamatory video. Like Bad Empanada's other videos, the
Bad Empanada video cited by Samson is replete with misinformation.
In the Bad Empanada video, Bad Empanada asserts that Ethan Klein
attempts to justify the Israeli settler colonial state by glossing
over the Nakba. Bad Empanada video 0 to
0:06 to 13. Not only is this false, but Bad Empanada also fails
to show any clips of Ethan doing so. Rather, Bad Empanada shows
Ethan discussing one, that Jews would not
feel safe as an ethnic minority. Two, Israel is com Israel is
comprised of refugees from Europe and Arab countries. Three,
following the 1948 war, there were more Jews displaced than Palestinians
during the Nakba. And four, see, this is like This is saying
the slow remigration over years and decades
or sorry, I said remigration. It's not remigration. I don't I
I don't know why I'm saying it that way. The slow migration of
of people from around Israel over decades is equivalent to what
happened in that tiny space of time
during and after the Arab-Israeli War. That is trying to say
that the Palestinians who were forced from their homes are suffering
similar things than the But it's not, all right? It's all at
once. All expelled at once. Tons of people expelled at once.
And I don't think it's even really remotely deniable that that
was Israel's plan and that they actually did things like poisoning
wells, like blowing up towns explicitly so people couldn't return.
I I believe Benny Morris has documented like all of this, no?
Has Has Benny Morris not literally documented this? I I could
have sworn the well poisoning thing. I thought that was quite
literally a thing that happened. That like people got removed
from their homes and then the wells were were obliterated.
It was all part of plan C, but they enacted this, no? I don't
know so I know they had multiple plans. Did they Did they get
to that?
I know Is this
>> Sorry. So this is uh there are hardly any Jews left
in Arab countries. So Ethan just denies that the these four
can add up to Nakba like that they're Nakba denial is talking
points. Not that you're denying the Nakba happened, but they're
Nakba denial is talking points that are used to say, "Well, actually
Israelis Israelis needed Israel because look what happened to
them in all these other countries."
That's what That's what the argument is here, right?
But it's not even attempting to engage with that. None of these
statements deny the Nakba or downplay it.
They do downplay it. And this has been explained to you multiple
times. I think it's been explained to him multiple times by multiple
people. I want to say I've seen Destiny agreeing with um the
Overzealous guy that Ethan Klein needs to be really careful,
right? When Ethan made this argument during the debate with Hasan?
I think that like Destiny watched that and was like, "Whoa, Ethan,
careful now. Don't Do not try to compare these things. This is
a little too much, dude. It's uh it's a lot. It's a lot.
Yeah, let me keep going.
Uh rather, it is a fact that approximately 900,000
migrated, fled, or were expelled from Muslim majority countries
throughout Africa and Asia, primarily as a consequence of the
establishment of the state of Israel. And the Nakba turned 700,000
Palestinians into refugees, which was mainly caused by Israeli
arms.
Even worse, the Badempanada video advances an ahistorical narrative
about the exodus of Jews from Morocco, Algeria, and Iraq.
Badempanada is not a part of the lawsuit. I don't know why this
would I don't know why this would matter at all.
I'm not I don't even care to like read this part. It doesn't
matter.
Badempanada literally could have said
"Ethan killed his dog with cheese. Ethan killed his dog with
cheese. Ethan killed his dog with cheese." That could be the
entirety of the next 45 minutes of runtime after this initial
stuff. It doesn't matter. You're not suing Badempanada for defamation.
It's It's weird, man. As to Morocco, Badempanada grossly misrepresents
the historical record by claiming that the agency struck an agreement
with the French governor to force Moroccan Jews to immigrate.
Badempanada video, I don't care. I literally don't care. Nobody
should care. None of this matters. You're not suing Badempanada.
Why Why is he doing a debunking? Make this a video or something.
Why are you doing a debunking of Badempanada in the middle of
your lawsuit with Noah Samson?
And what he lied about. It's basically the idea that more Jews
went here and then the temporal shift, the the idea that over
like 30-ish years, 30-plus years, that migrating to Israel over
time is significant and the same as the Nakba is insulting and
downplays the Nakba.
It doesn't matter whether or not it was like I know all of the
arguments they'll do. Oh, Israel went and did some like bombing,
some false flag bombings to get people to go over to Israel to
make them feel unsafe. I know all of these arguments. I don't
care about None of them matter to the core like assertions made
about in the lawsuit or about what Noah Samson believes. This
is goofy. Samson made the fourth defamatory statement with knowledge
of falsity or like Samson himself was an unreliable source of
information with an extreme bias against Ethan,
Israel, and Israelis. Oh, he knew that Badempanada like Samson
himself was an unreliable source of information with an extreme
bias against Ethan, Israel, and Israelis. The Badempanada video
did not identify a single statement by Ethan that supported the
assertion of Nakba
Didn't This is So you just lie at a base level in the lawsuit
and then continue on, I guess. Samson was more concerned with
the promulgating of uh with promulgating his false narrative
about denying atrocities made against Arab Jews to advance his
genocidal
The sixth defamatory statement. The sixth defamatory statement
falsely asserts that Ethan labeled Rashid al-Haddad al-Haddad
as a terrorist with zero credible evidence. I would say if his
evidence is Hasan [__] said he was a terrorist, I
think this is kind of rough. Maybe you could argue that he marketed
himself as a Houthi or something.
Zero credible evidence. The nuke shows various social media posts
of al-Haddad admitting to being a Houthi terrorist, expressing
support for the Houthis, and echoing their genocidal rhetoric.
Admitting to being a Houthi terrorist. I
I don't know. It's weird cuz I'm just getting conflicting reports.
He told Hasan that he wasn't,
right? Not that like I'm just saying
It seems like he's going back and forth on this. I don't know
if he was saying he admitted to being a Houthi. Fox News accurately
labeled him as a Houthi sympathizer instead of a member. Okay.
Sixth defamatory statement falsely asserts that Ethan labeled
Rashid al-Haddad al-Haddad as a terrorist with zero credible
evidence. The nuke shows various social media posts of al-Haddad
admitting to being a Houthi terrorist, expressing support for
Houthis, and echoing their genocidal rhetoric. The nuke also
shows clips of al-Haddad discussing visiting the Galaxy Leader,
i.e. the ship hijacked by the Houthis, and interacting with the
hostage taken with the hostage taking crew.
Despite claiming to have seen the nuke, Samson fails to disclose,
let alone explain, why the social media posts and interviews
cited by Ethan in the nuke failed to support Ethan's claim that
al-Haddad was a member of the Houthis. Samson failed to do so
because he knew he could not do so. So I think as long as there
So I don't I think they kept the crew on the ship and it seemed
like people could go to the ship if they were if they wanted
to. It was like a tourist attraction of some
And then as far as him claiming it, I guess you could say him
claiming it is enough for you to believe that. But then it comes
down to what the fact of the matter is, right? It seems like
the guy himself
like sued Ethan for defamation or said he was going to sue Ethan
for defamation. So it seems like he's refuting it specifically.
Hasan posted debunking it, but that never happened. Apparently
that guy never met the crew. It was a mistranslation or misunder
an misunderstanding. He was on the ship, yes. Oh, and then he
never met with the crew? Dude, I might have hallucinated that.
I believe that 100%.
retraction demand and Samson's response. So, you know, speaking
to the lawsuit at a more meta
it is very interesting that you usually don't see this a lot
of the time. A lot of the time people will just capitulate here
because until you get a retraction demand, a cease and desist
of some kind, and refuse to honor it,
you can get out of basically every defamation suit in the United
States by
By recanting, by changing your video, changing your statements,
and saying that was wrong. Here you go, right? And usually people
at the risk of getting sued will just do that cuz it's way
We're in a We're in new ground here. Breaking new ground because
Noah Samson very clearly said, "Nah, [__] off."
Right? "Nah, [__] off." Ethan did Noah did a video.
He wasn't unaware that the demand had been published. He did
a video. He responded, okay? He did a video. He responded, and
he stood on business. So he refused to comply Now, I believe,
you know, one of the hardest things to prove with regards to
a defamation claim is actual malice.
Right? By refusing to honor the the or comply with the retraction
demand, you I believe give actual malice to the other person.
You're saying, "No, no, no. This isn't a lie, and I'm I know
you're saying it's a lie. I've looked into it. I stand by these
statements."
Right? So that's It's a little different cuz that's usually the
hardest part to prove, but when you refuse the takedown notice,
I do believe that that sort of starts to give you actual malice,
right?
Anyway, we'll keep reading. On March 31st, 2025, Ethan sent Samson
a demand for a retraction out of an abundance of caution, the
retraction demand. The retraction demand was sent to the email
address Samson provided on his YouTube page, noah@sparkmedia.la.
Physical copy was sent to Spark Media Inc. The retraction demand
was 16 pages long. Explained in exacting detail why the defamatory
statements were false and supported the assertions with numerous
Samson refused to comply with the retraction demand. Furthermore,
he began to flaunt his refusal to comply with with the retraction
demand and continued to attack Ethan along with Ela as detailed
below.
On May 15th, 2025, Samson released a video stating he would not
comply with the retraction demand, even though the deadline to
comply had long passed, and called it a joke.
Samson would go on to make a number of videos and social media
posts that doubled down on his claims against
uh Ethan attacked Ela as a war criminal, and attacked their Arab
employees as race traitors.
On December 14th, 2025, Samson was interviewed where he continued
to taunt Ethan into suing him. Again, while these are bad things
to do,
po- potentially, okay? You can argue it's not something you do
in polite com- company. It is constitutionally protected speech.
I can say, "You. I hate you. I think your employees are race
traitors." You can do that. Turns out even neo-Nazis get get
uh defended by this, okay? You yell that like somebody's a race
traitor cuz they're an interracial couple. That unfortunately
is constitutionally protected speech.
You can be racist.
Unlucky. Very unlucky.
Anyway, Ethan repeats and realleges. So first cause of action,
defamation. Ethan repeats and realleges each of the fore- foregoing
paragraphs as if set forth fully herein. Defendants published
false and defamatory statements about Ethan to a worldwide internet
au- audience by posting the defamatory video. Oh, here's the
next part, though. Because it's a defamation suit, you have to
prove damages. So what are the damages to your reputation? So
this will be funny cuz basically Ethan Klein is going to have
to give us for the damages he's seeking. He's going to have to
give us a a good idea of just how badly he fell the off, okay?
Right? Am Am I wrong? If you want to sue for damages, you got
to lay out what the damages are. How bad you fall off, little
bro? You fall off pretty hard or What was your revenue before?
How far has your revenue gone down? This should be a inventory
of just how bad Ethan fell off.
>> No, no, no. I'm just What's going to be funny here is
he doesn't really
This is the problem is he's giving the sarcas all they want everything
they want here, right? If he's going to make the argument correctly,
he's going to have to argue just how badly he fell off. So I
do want to see. Right? Cuz I think if they're if you aren't arguing
for damages, if you're not saying how much the damages are, I
don't know how far you get to go with the defamation lawsuit.
So he's going to have to say Noah Samson actually destroyed my
internet career.
That's what he's got to do.
Right? I don't know if we get to see internal stats. I don't
think you have to do that, but he should have some idea of the
revenue, right? That he's lost or some idea of the viewership
he's lost.
defendants published false and defamatory statements blah blah
blah blah blah, but Ethan to a worldwide internet audience by
posting the defamatory video on Samson's YouTube channel on March
11th, 2025. The defamatory video contained numerous defamatory
statements about Ethan that are set forth below. The first defamatory
statement is the title of the defamatory video, i.e., These YouTubers
genocide. And the thumbnail of defamatory video, which is depicted
below.
Oh, wait. Okay, this is Sorry, is this the letter? Oh, this is
just restating all the stuff. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So Samson's defamatory
were intended and did falsely convey the
Oh, jeez. The first defamatory statement falsely conveyed that
Ethan materially or or morally supported Israel's genocide of
the Palestinian people in
Second and fifth defamatory statements falsely conveyed that
Ethan lied about Hamas engaging in violence and misrepresented
the UN report to justify Israel's actions in Gaza. So this is
Noah's not saying you did it for these reasons. He's saying that
is the consequence of what you did. When you argue when you argue
these atrocities are worse than they were,
you are actually
in effect
manufacturing consent for the actions in Gaza. That is the argument.
If the title wrong, it's not the it's the not these. Oh, okay.
I don't think that's super relevant, but it's fine.
So second and fifth defamatory statements are about violence.
The third defamatory statement is that he made false statements
about Hezbollah and the Houthis. The fourth defamatory statement
falsely conveys that Ethan denied the Nakba to justify Israel's
existence. The sixth defamatory statement falsely conveys that
Ethan branded Al Hadada terrorist with no factual support to
advance a pro-Israel
So like I don't think when when Noah's speaking quite specifically
about like what he means, I don't think you quite get to argue
these things. Like they're direct lines. Like if Noah directly
argues these things, maybe it gets a little stronger.
But he is it's mostly a manufacturing consent argument except
for this one, the statements about the Houthis and Hezbollah.
This one seems to be a direct statement saying you lied about
Hezbollah and the Houthis and you probably are going to have
to back that up with where Ethan has lied. We'll see. To make
it like an opinion.
Right? So so you'll have to say, well, it's my opinion that he
lied because
I hear like the the sources I would
See. Samson's statements which refer to Ethan by name or likeness
are reasonably understood to be statements of fact about Ethan.
No, they're not. And were understood by people who read them
to be statements of fact about Ethan. They're they're literally
understood and you're going to find this. So I looked at a citation
from a from case law earlier today before I started the It seems
like most of the time for especially for heated political arguments,
people assume the the court assumes that these things will be
read as opinion.
Now they've done an argument here to say, well, he presented
himself as an expert and so because he's an expert, I
Yeah, because he's an expert that these are statements of fact.
Well, the factual statement that you that there's a genocide
happening, that's already something that's totally contentious,
right? Like nobody argues that that's a fact that that a genocide
is happening. Sorry, nobody
as a neutral third-party observer, you would say, well, you can't
prove this factually. It's like a line that is argued about,
right? Did he present himself as an expert? That could be another
thing you argue about, right? That's Ethan's argument is he presented
himself as an expert. I don't believe he said I am an expert
on
It's that he's speaking authoritatively, I guess. I'm sure there
are ways you could look at this and how these same arguments
would affect things downstream. Like if you're doing a drama
video and you or if you're talking [__] about somebody,
but you sound authoritative while doing it, does that mean you're
making factual statements? Do you really think that guy like
Do you really think that guy's mom is really fat? Well, that's
defamatory. She is in fact a normal BMI. Are you sure that that
Are you sure You're you're You sounded pretty authoritative when
you said that. Are you sure that that wasn't a statement of fact
and a defamation of his mom?
Right? Like there's something going on here where it's like that's
essentially what I'm seeing and it's I just don't see how you
could do that. Samson's statements are false as discussed below.
First defamatory statement is false because Ethan has not morally
or materially supported Israel's genocide of the Palestinian
people. Um, disagree with Like this is based on their definition,
right? So they're going to all of these things and they made
an argument for this, but it is based on the dictionary definitions
of genocide and support or backed
in this case. Backed and genocide. God. I just I don't need to
read all of this again. I've got a good idea of what it is. Samson's
statements are defamatory and libelous per se. Their defamatory
meaning is apparent on their face without the necessity of explanatory
matter. Yeah, without the necessity of explanatory matter because
they accuse Ethan of materially or morally supporting Israel's
genocide of the Palestinian people by spreading factually and
demonstrably false statements. Samson's statements have exposed
Ethan to hatred and contempt and have injured him in his occupation
as an online Ah, here we go. How bad did you fall off? How bad
did you fall off? Tell me. Hold on.
And have injured him in his occupation as an online content creator
and the owner of a streetwear company. Samson's statements were
calculated to and in fact it did in fact provoke outrage and
cause Ethan reputational and financial damage to the defendant's
benefit both financially and reputationally.
Defendants have no applicable privilege or legal authorization
to publish these false and defamatory statements or if they did,
they abused it. And as set forth above in detail and summarized
below, defendants published the defamatory statements with act
with actual malice.
As to the first it was made with act first as to the first defamatory
statement, it was made with actual malice because amongst other
things defendants one, knew Ethan Klein did not support Israel's
genocide by having reviewed the nuke. Two, engaged in identical
behavior by citing the Anas video and Turkey Tom video to claim
they support Israel's genocide despite Anas and Turkey Tom expressly
stating the opposite. It's just totally totally disconnected
entirely from the argument being made. There's only so many times
I can read the same argument going on. I'm sorry. It's These
are all the same arguments happening again, right?
If I could have, I would have just, you know, gone to here. But
we've read all of these. We've gone through it. Okay, this is
just a summary of these things.
I don't know why they're re-summarizing again. Maybe for the
sake of people reading, but they're re-summarizing these exact
arguments they'd already made even though they said assume the
previous paragraphs are set forth herein, which is really unfortunate.
Samson made these false and defamatory statements intentionally,
willfully, and maliciously and in conscious disregard for Ethan's
rights and reputation and of the truth. Samson's defamatory falsehoods
have been repeated and republished by numerous people, which
was reasonably foreseeable uh reasonably foreseeable to and specifically
intended and expected by defendants.
As a result and foreseeable result Sorry, as a direct and foreseeable
result of Samson's false and defamatory accusations, Ethan has
suffered financial and reputational harm. As a result of Samson's
false and defamatory accusations, Ethan's relationships with
members of his community, his current and prospective business
partners, and other individuals with whom Ethan has known and
interacted with have been irreparably damaged.
As a result of Samson's false and defamatory accusations, threatening
statements have been directed at Ethan and his family causing
Ethan emotional
I'm pretty sure the skulls got sent before this.
But okay.
So he's basically saying um this guy destroyed all my friendships.
Certainly not attacking your friends. Certainly not taking a
friend you had who was like barely saying anything cuz they disagreed
with you by the way and attacking them. Surely that couldn't
have affected friendships. I don't think so. It's all Noah Samson.
As a result of Samson's false and defamatory accusations, Ethan
has been forced to make an expenditure of money to remedy the
defamation including an expenditure of attorney's fees.
Ethan is entitled to exemplary damages because defendants' publication
of these defamatory statements was accompanied by malice, fraud,
and oppression and a conscious desire to cause injury. Defendants
acted with reckless and willful indifference to Ethan's rights.
Ethan is entitled to exemplary damages because defendants published
these false and defamatory statements about Ethan with actual
malice. In the view of the in view of the foregoing, Ethan is
entitled to general, special, and exemplary damages in an amount
to be determined determined at
Prayer for relief. Wherefore Ethan prays for judgment against
defendants Noah Samson and Samson Creative LLC as follows, ordering
Ethan general and special damages, ordering Ethan punitive and
exemplary damages, ordering Ethan all expenses and costs including
attorney's fees. So he doesn't say what the damages are. They
did not calculate the damages, which
So this will be the initial thing and then I guess they'll get
into damages. It sucks that they're not going to say it. You
look at this up before Noah's video is already crashing, so you
have to do it beforehand. That's going to be a rough argument
for him to make in court then.
You know, it's going to be quite difficult to make that argument
in court if they were already crashing before Ethan had done
anything before Sorry, this had been published. Now we it's time
to get to like commentary and stuff on this. I will say
the Hezbollah point does seem like that possibly is wrong.
in terms of the calculation of damages, if that's determined
to be a thing a thing Noah like knowingly lied about, knowingly
refused to back down from, and let's say it's wrong, how much
did that statement contribute to any reputational damage?
I will be reviewing Ethan Klein's anti-free speech defamation
lawsuit at Oh, Ethan Klein's anti-free speech defamation lawsuit
against No Sam said I Yeah, I didn't realize he said that. I
thought he was just going to review the
I didn't realize he'd already cast
>> That's funny. Bro, this guy's going hard in the paint.
Didn't even see it. He's like, nah, it's anti-free speech. I
would say it is anti-free speech because honestly none of us
look at Noa Sam's video and go this is like totally defamatory.
I understand what he's arguing. He's arguing that he's manufactured
consent. He's keeping the status quo in place. That is what the
effect of his coverage of Israel-Palestine has done. That is
what it adds up to. Ethan doesn't like this fact. He doesn't
like you pointing out this fact. So, he's going to sue you for
pointing out this fact, but he's wrong. He's He's just wrong.
And he has one defense for the government of Israel through his
actions, through repeatedly attacking people who are on the pro-Palestinian
side.
And through constantly re- re-justify Sorry, re-emphasizing the
plight of the Israeli people, which is by magnitude, orders of
magnitude less than anything the Palestinians have suffered through
in the past 3 years. Consistently refocusing on anti-Semitism
and your problems
while attacking the people who are trying to point out the Palestinian
stuff, that is absolutely
a problem. He justified bombing Lebanon just today? I'm sure
he did. I have that streamable. Hold on. We had that streamable
up earlier. Well, give me a second. Okay, this is on the stream
today. >> I'm actually disappointed in him because I always
thought he was such a talented, funny guy that didn't need any
of those people and he just fell right in to the and now he's
partying with Candace Owens. What a
waste. That was a wild left turn because he used to be so funny.
Like kind of with his delivery was great. Like not trying too
hard. Just naturally off the >> He's still funny. >> Yeah,
but how did he end up I don't understand like how did that trajectory
>> know, they got him. But he really fell hardcore for
the like Israel is behind everything. Yep. That's what >> Hardcore.
What do you think is going to happen? You think we're going to
be Theo, yeah, okay. Ethan thought Theo is still funny. Theo
was funny in that he's like, I think my brain's man, I THINK
I THINK I'M LIKE LOSING MY MIND, MAN. I THINK I'M LOSING IT.
>> It was funny. It was funny. He's like, DUDE, I CAN'T
STOP TALKING. I can't stop thinking about Israel, man. I my my
Yeah, but how did he end up I don't understand like how did that
trajectory >> know, they got him. But he really fell hardcore
for the like Israel is behind everything. Yep. That's what
Wait, what did he Wait, hold on now. What did he fall for here?
What do you think is going to happen? You think we're going to
be okay? I hope so.
What did Hold on. Wait, what did he say? I can't remember what
he said that was so far off. I just thought he was like spiraling.
I didn't even necessarily like disagree with some of the stuff
he said. I just thought he was spiraling. Why is E will be like
E will be like
Theo was so awesome before he had problem with Israel. Theo was
so awesome before he had a real problem with Israel. He was actually
better. Countless people say BB's yarmulke head. That was funny
though. I'm sorry. That might have been like Israel, but she
said Israel's behind everything. Dude, that was That was maybe
the best part of the podcast. That was some some of the funniest
[__] I've ever heard.
They call him yarmulke Hitler. Who calls him that? Uh, tons of
people.
Like who? Countless. Countless people.
>> Oh, of course. >> I don't know. Do you think about
it? >> I'm confused. I can't believe we went to this war.
I When they started bombing Iran, I was like, this can't This
can't be true. >> And what about Lebanon now? >> I
know. Israel's invaded Lebanon. Yeah. Yeah. And it's like just
stop it. What do you need? Well, they're trying Okay, if you're
going if you're going to have a conversation about it, it should
don't be like This is again the most biggest podcast in the world.
It's like, what are you Why are you doing all these things, Israel?
But like there are there are reasons that you could ask someone
about. Yeah, they thirst for blood. They are evil by nature.
There I see it. That's Honestly,
that's That explains it better cuz realistically any pragmatic
concern actually doesn't make sense.
Just optically to the world when Hezbollah is at their absolute
weakest to go in and start detonating all the civilian homes
in southern Lebanon, there is no pragmatic explanation for this.
It looks so awful to every human being who watches it. It is
setting back Israel's
the view everybody in the world has of Israel so far. It is absolute
confirmation of every single person who said that Israelis are
genocidal with regards to the Palestinians, they're genocidal,
they're going to do to everybody. It is reaffirming every single
narrative people have about this place and trust me it was very
hard to argue like a lot of the stuff about Israel like kind
of having this like evil intent. It was quite hard to argue it
without a like obvious and on its face proof. And Lebanon is
giving everybody that. It's like basically like we set up an
experiment and Gaza was the first thing and Lebanon, you are
like validating the experiment. You are like, hey, Israel's got
some brand new terrorist threat that they're going to like go
and show exactly how to use a terrorist threat to ethnically
cleanse a whole bunch of people. Boom. Oh, they're blowing up
homes. Oh, they're like blowing up bridges. They're making sure
nobody ever can ever come back. It's like the the validation
of the hypothesis that we have like we've we've replicated the
study. We've replicated the Israelis Are Israelis evil? Yes.
I I
I contend yes. And then we've replicated that in a second country
now. Like incontrovertibly yes. That's what I'm going to say.
It's crazy. So, I don't actually think like evil ontologically
evil. No, I'm not going to say I don't actually think that. It's
funny to say. But like unfortunately, there's just no good defense
of this.
The defense is Hezbollah fires rockets at us from there. Well,
I thought you just destroyed Iran's ability to like help fund
Hezbollah. Hezbollah is like in shambles. You destroyed the entire
leadership. You decapitated the entire control like the command
control of Hezbollah. What was the point of doing any of that
if just like, you know, less than a year later or around a year
later you're right back to this is such a such a massive threat.
We need to not only ethnically cleanse the Shia Muslims from
this area. We need to call up all their neighbors and tell them,
if you house any of these Shia Muslims that are fleeing, if you
give them succor, if you give them help, if you render any aid
to them, we will kill you. We will kill your family. We will
blow your house up. Do not take any of them in. Like that What
What am I supposed to think about that? What am I supposed to
think when that's happening?
So, anyway, that's all to say, now let's let Ethan Klein cook
cuz that's my view of it. But what's Ethan Klein's view? Maybe
Ethan's got a different view. Maybe Ethan has like a totally
different view. Maybe he'll explain that they're doing all of
that cuz actually it's like code. They're like, maybe just don't
take terrorists in, but you can take like women and children
in, maybe. Maybe it's all code. >> I mean again, Israel
only invaded Lebanon when they started launching rockets again.
That's why yeah, I always don't understand the conversations
where [snorts] it's like, why is Israel doing all that? >> Well,
there is a reason. So, like if you want to actually like have
a real conversation about >> being shot at from all directions.
Houthis, Leb- Lebanon and Iran. Yeah, so you you guys are willing
to justify any and all
Dude, the kickers having problems. Sorry, these Yeah, the kickers
having just massive problems. This [__] is very annoying.
Well, for a long time it was just Iran. And like Hezbollah >> time.
No, Hezbollah just recently got into it. They were staying out
of it. >> I mean, you're saying a long. It's not that long.
>> since this whole with Iran started. >> Yeah, for
years it was from Gaza.
>> Yeah. So, I'm just saying like, you I'm No, I thought
I think Hezbollah threw some some jabs in every once in a while,
no? I thought Hezbollah for like the past, I don't know, decade
were basically consistently throwing, you know, a couple rockets
in here or there, no? Pretty sure if Theo Von if there was rockets
coming from Mexico, he wouldn't be like, yo, what's with America,
bro? Why why
Hold on. If rockets were coming in from Mexico, I wouldn't think
you can go into Juarez or
uh, what's the other place with the tequila? Um, Tijuana and
destroy all civilian housing.
That wouldn't be acceptable.
We we wouldn't say, oh yeah, kill displace all the Mexicans and
then actually take a buffer zone all the way up to some random
geographical point and ethnically cleanse them all and destroy
all housing in the area. And if that happened, I would be I'd
be livid. I would be saying the United States is like some kind
of great Satan. Like it would be evil. >> they just leave
Mexico alone? And granted, you know, Israel, I don't know what's
their We would do it though. Well, I think No, I think America
realized No, no, no. America, you can read American military
doctrine and how it changed after Iraq because they realized
how disastrous this rule by force strategy is in any place that
is like diametrically opposed to you. They realized that it was
unworkable. You cannot fight an urban insurgency. You have to
kill everybody. They realized it was totally unworkable and you
can never actually change the civilian populace's mind or work
towards any real solutions so long as they hate you more than
the people who are already oppressing them.
It cannot work. >> What they're up to with trying trying
to annex territory from Lebanon, that's a new thing. That doesn't
sound very good.
again, if you want to have a conversation about it, talk about
the facts so that we can I So, this is always the thing. I'm
I'm like very critical of Israel, but like why do you Why do
you lie about what's happening in
I'm sorry. We're going to go from the what's what the consequences
are for the Lebanese people. We're going to start from there
and we're going to work from a framework of you have to tell
me all of these things are happening and then once I'm aware
that you're aware of all of the the that are happening, then
we could continue the conversation. You need to keep those things
in mind while you're having the conversation. So, you could say,
"Okay, lots of rockets have been fired by Hezbollah from towards
Israel during this war with Iran." So, the war with Iran that
Israel's being consistently attempting to provoke for years and
years and years. Okay, war with Iran directly. And also, Iran
and their ability to build up missiles, build up almost anything
has been massively hampered. So, Hezbollah should be at their
weakest they've been at in a long time. Assad is no longer in
Syria. It is very difficult to run guns from Iran to Hezbollah
in in Lebanon.
essentially, I think Hezbollah is probably never been weaker
than they are right now. Hezbollah is like at its weakest. Why
is it now that you're trying to justify ethnically cleansing
Southern Lebanon? This is the worst time. This is the worst time
you could have picked to do this in terms of how you justify
it to anybody else.
That's my issue. >> actually decide like what's
What is why are they're doing it and what's bad about it?
And like also, what what like The other thing [laughter] is like
Hezbollah Lebanon government is trying to get rid of Hezbollah.
And Hezbollah is [__] everything up there.
Dude, it's like
Please, please, somebody take this edit and just edit in all
of the buildings being destroyed in Southern Lebanon.
Edit in this the time C4 detonations of rows of houses.
You are psychotic.
Trying to run defense for this. You are psychotic. They were
supposed to [__] off, right? The Lebanese people
don't want Hezbollah there and everything was Israel was no longer
bombing them to unironically doing the same
that Israel and the United States were doing to justify bombing
Iran in the first place. Well, actually, they don't really want
the dictators there, so we had to bomb all these oil depots and
totally destroy their capacity for happiness, totally put their
lives, set them back decades. We had to do it cuz they don't
like their leader.
Are you sure that they didn't like their leader enough to have
their entire way of life destroyed? Cuz I don't know if that's
true. I I understand that like there's some capacity if you were
going to go in boots on the ground and try to overthrow the regime
in Iran, maybe there's some like a very large subset of that
population that would help you. But just bombing them, bombing
all of their amenities, their way of life? Bombing them back
to the Stone Age as the US called it. How in the world
are you supposed to justify that? As well, we we wanted to like
help the
Where? What how? Oh, I didn't even think about this. Was AB present?
AB was present today. We saw them at the beginning. How did AB
sit through this? How did AB sit through this and listen?
Oh, no.
Cuz I could understand it in a lot of other cases.
But right now? Oh,
that's tough, man. That's actually tough. That's a rough >> started
launching rockets again in their slavish dedication to the Islamic
state of Iran. Mhm. And now they're Now all this is happening
again in Lebanon, which isn't good for anybody. So, again, that
it's just like bro, just try to talk to someone other than Candace
Owens at least. Yeah. And it's like just stop it. What do you
need?
Well, they're trying to supposedly they're trying to stop the
terrorists.
What is it Why is it funny? Why is it What's funny to you? Maybe
try like try actually listening to what's happening there and
not Candace. I mean, there are Hezbollah launching rockets. I
I I understand what you're talking about. What are you talking
about? Talking about Trump? >> No, he's he's talking about
>> No, he's No, he's not. >> No, he's saying why
is Israel doing all that? He's saying Israel it doesn't >> What do
they need? What are they looking for? He's talking It doesn't
matter. But I was just Also, it's not Trump. Also, we haven't
read that article yet, but it's not Trump. It's everything
I said, okay, everything we said right from the beginning.
for some reason getting fooled, getting totally bamboozled by
Bibi and complete lies that all of his group disagreed
Right? It makes no sense. It's so crazy.
He's about to say Israel is the
hold on. We go back a little bit. >> I think Israel it
doesn't What do they need? What are they looking for? He's talking
It doesn't matter. But I was just We were talking about how uh
Theo became part of this like um Israel like
conspiracy theories, frankly, like Israel conspiracy theories,
like they run the shots and call all the shots in the world and
do everything
uh negative in the whole world all the time. You can stop it.
What do you need?
Well, they're trying to uh supposedly they're trying to stop
the terrorists. Yeah, that's crazy though if you're the
>> I mean, again, that's really cute and and cool that
you can say that and everyone applauds. But again, they're retaliating
to them shooting rockets into civilian areas. So, I mean, again,
How did Hezbollah form, Ethan? Hey, Ethan, what How did Hezbollah
get formed? Hey, Ethan, how did Hezbollah get start How did When
was that formed? What happened? What happened here? Ethan Klein?
How did Hezbollah get made? If we're going to go back in time
and we're going to do the whole like oh consequences and stuff?
This is what happens when you hang out with Candace Owens all
the time. What? I just went back and checked the the conversation
is about Iran.
He's talking about Lebanon.
It's You can go back. It's about I think it's Lebanon. I mean,
yeah. I I have a little bit of different feelings again with
Theo. I appreciate him at least, you know, he may not have all
of his facts right and you You got to You got to
Okay, this could be rough. This could be rough right here. >> but
I do appreciate at least someone on his side talking about what's
going on. But a lot of people Theo was funny, but Theo was like
way too black-pilled and way too down some rabbit holes. Like
he had I think everything he said about Lebanon was
I think all the stuff he said about Lebanon was correct. Overall,
he was way too black-pilled. He clearly gets like stuck in social
media spiraling all day. >> People are and I feel like
He acts like he's doing it at great cost to somebody, but he's
not. He's being applauded and paraded around. He's popular. Everybody's
celebrating him. He's falling He's falling so easily to anti-Semitic
talking points. It's just
It's ridiculous when everything in your life becomes Israel's
fault. Yeah, and I don't agree obviously with like hanging in
with Candace Owens and people like that. The anti-Semitism
of saying what the [__] is was Israel doing by going
into Lebanon? That insanely anti-Semitic talking point of Come
on, man. What more do you need? You're going into Lebanon now.
What more do you need, man? People when everything is Israel's
fault. I think the pro There are clips of him that are really
good like in isolation.
Like the clips that go viral of him like speaking on behalf of
Palestine and saying like [clears throat] the things that are
going on there are horrible and he sees the war and all the terrible
[__] that's happening by the IDF and got And like
that stuff's good, right? That stuff's good to see, but this
kind of clip here where he it's just like uh I understand with
this recent situation, yeah, that Hezbollah uh shot rockets first.
I think I think he's saying more in general sense the Joe saying
that they're trying to get the terrorists supposedly is like
that's been an excuse as well for a lot of horrible you know,
sometimes, you know, legitimate, but a lot of other times
to bomb indiscriminately. But That's the softest pushback
that you could possibly give.
Let's see how offended people get cuz that's obviously true.
get the terrorists supposedly is like that's been an excuse as
well for a lot of you know, sometimes, you know, legitimate,
but a lot of other times
to bomb indiscriminately. But that yeah, but that is what living
in Israel is and that's and it's really
She's trying to say that like you get shot and then you have
to shoot back. But it's so funny that she just said it that way.
And sometimes, they use it to bomb indiscriminately. And that's
really what living in Israel is. It's just like bombing people
indiscriminately.
frustrating whenever people talk about it here. It's like they
just removed that part. Like things are not just happening for
no reason. Everybody like my family is not happy being in the
bomb shelter all day. Everybody would rather be living in peace.
Mhm. The [clears throat] problem is this.
Should Israel blow up a city block >> cuz a missile was
launched there? Obviously not, right?
That's horrific, but at the same time
he's looking at the stuff and he's still
How? How? How? How? How? Does it Do you really need somebody
to
if you're willing to nuke somebody because somebody fired an
AK-47 over the
Is Do I need to say, "Well, technically, you shot the AK-47 over
the border."? It's Dude, actually way better example,
domestic violence. Ethan Klein is doing the the thing that people,
you know, victim blamers do. It's a little goofy. It's just It
feels a little bizarre to me. I don't know how to explain it.
Where are we going with that, right?
Like it's it's a totally disproportionate response that's inexcusable
and you are consistently going, Yeah, but what about like the
the provocation? What about that little provocation? If you're
going to have a conversation about it, don't be like, "They're
just bombing them for fun." >> for no reason. That's what's
really frustrating. That's also like unproductive and stupid.
Because the truth is what Israel's doing is [__]
up because they go, "Oh, there I think there's a terrorist in
this building. Let's blow up the whole city block." That's unacceptable.
That's a war crime. That's [__] up, right? Yeah,
I've I've seen a lot of times with like people Has nobody gotten
Ethan to ever think about how when you constantly ask for these
throat clearers, when you constantly try to point out other people's
like slight hyperbole in these
You are
manufacturing consent for the status quo. You're going, "Look
at these silly absurd people who are mad about this. Look at
how they like blow everything out of proportion." It's wild.
It's wild and it like it doesn't make sense. And he pretends
he doesn't understand the argument from Noam Chomsky.
How do you not understand it? It's very obvious. You're doing
it now. People who like just got into it and I'm like you know,
it's sort of the same trend of like oh, they're speaking about
it. Thank God they're bringing it to a new audience. And then
like they're I'm like cheering them on and then it seems like
at some point, not with everyone, but with some people that they
just go too far. And I was like, okay, now you're dipping too
far into like conspiracy theories sometimes. >> do that
and like being pro-Israel, too, But because they get like um
they get like audience
valid- or like even social media validation where like they see
that people are like, yeah, this is great. And then they probably
see a bunch of other people saying crazy [__] and
they're not very thoughtful or looking into it and so they get
more radicalized by their own like audience sometimes. Mhm. But
I I see that on both sides,
He's listen, like That's what you want to hear. While Israel
is committing a genocide and an ethnic cleansing at the same
going to hear you want to hear Well, I hear some some hyperbole
from both
Very There's very fine people on both sides here, guys. Very
fine people on both sides. We're all good. We're all good. There's
some very good Israelis. >> But why are these two guys
talking about it like at least I mean this is Joe Rogan, at least
bring in somebody that knows about the situation like real knowledge
to to be a part of it. You have Theo Von who's a comedian and
Joe Rogan who's a wannabe comedian talking about the >> He's not
even a comedian. talking about the Middle East like Yeah, it's
it's just frustrating because like >> Yeah, cuz like I'm
all That That makes sense. Uh I'm all for these guys talking
about anything and I know we talk about like Israel all the time,
but is there any excuse for talking about Israel
when you don't have experts there? Bring somebody on who can
defend Israel now.
Cool. So cool. Very cool. Very awesome. I'm on board for criticizing
Israel, but it's hard to have a conversation about it when like
the premise is Israel's just dropping bombs for fun in Lebanon.
Because then you have to like backtrack
and it's like you almost have to defend Israel when they're doing
stuff that's indefensible and it's frustrating. Because like,
well, they're not bombing them for no reason. Like they're shooting
rockets and they're responding to that. And then all of a sudden
you're defending Israel, right? And especially in their mind
when everything is so like black and white. It's like you're
pro or against. And then but it's like, well, that's because
you have to like have at least the the foundational premise to
have a conversation about it. Because I I prob- I agree with
him, but at the same time, you know, that context is important.